Hello and welcome to your second drink of the surplus.
This is the episode where Oscar explains to Michael that he has to spend the office surplus,
and it kicks off this big debate over what the bullpen wants to spend it on.
Chairs are a new copier.
This is also when Dwight takes Angela and Andy to Shrewd Farms.
It was a very fun episode of the Office, one of my favorite to shoot, and also one of my favorite episodes of Office Ladies.
So listen, lady, I was revisiting this one.
and I did this deep dive on butter sculptures at the Iowa State Fair because when Angela is talking about planning her wedding,
你好，欢迎收听第二杯“盈余”。这一集里，奥斯卡向迈克尔解释他必须花掉办公室的盈余，这引发了关于办公区应该把钱花在什么地方的大辩论。椅子还是新复印机。这也是德怀特带安吉拉和安迪去施鲁特农场的那一集。这是《办公室》非常有趣的一集，是我拍摄时最喜欢的一集，也是我最喜欢的《办公室女士》剧集之一。所以听着，女士，我重温了这一集，并深入研究了爱荷华州博览会上的黄油雕塑，因为当安吉拉谈到筹划她的婚礼时，
she says she wants a cat butter sculpture.
I remember when we did our stories, you sent me all of these pictures you found of butter sculptures.
Yes.
Well, guess what?
I have an update.
Okay.
A butter sculpture update.
I want everyone to know that the Iowa State Fair will be going on this year from August 13th to 23rd.
她说她想要一个猫咪黄油雕塑。我记得当我们讲故事时，你发给我所有你找到的黄油雕塑照片。是的。嗯，你猜怎么着？我有一个更新。好的。一个黄油雕塑的更新。我想让大家知道，今年的爱荷华州博览会将于8月13日至23日举行。
and yes, there will be a butter cow per usual.
And it will be sculpted by Sarah Pratt,
who has been making the butter cow since 2006.
Her two daughters, Hannah and Grace, are now her apprentices.
And listen, I'm telling you, I got so interested in these sculptures again
that I ended up watching some videos of Sarah and her daughters from last year's fair.
And they use their hands a lot to do the sculpting.
I don't know what I was expecting. Tools, I don't know. I totally envision it as like them using their hands, like almost like a clay, like making pottery. That is what it was like. I envisioned it like, I don't know, like an old timey like chisel and hammer. But no, they do. They use their hands to mold it. And then it cools into the shape that they're going for. It's really fascinating. I want to watch it. And one day, I need to see these butter sculptures in real life. Can we please do this?
是的，照常会有一头黄油牛。它将由莎拉·普拉特雕刻，她从2006年就开始制作黄油牛了。她的两个女儿，汉娜和格蕾丝，现在是她的学徒。听着，我告诉你，我又对这些雕塑产生了浓厚的兴趣，以至于我最后看了莎拉和她女儿们去年博览会的一些视频。她们用手做了很多雕刻工作。我不知道我期待的是什么。工具，我不知道。我完全想象她们是用手，就像用粘土，像做陶器一样。确实就是那样。我设想的是，我不知道，像老式的凿子和锤子。但没有，她们确实是这样做的。她们用手塑形。然后它冷却成她们想要的形状。这真的很迷人。我想看一看。有一天，我需要亲眼看看这些黄油雕塑。我们能这样做吗？
this lady, I mean it, I mean it.
My bags are packed.
Okay.
I mean, I am in.
I love butter.
I know you do.
And I love things sculpted out of other things, I guess.
This is a good match for us.
这位女士，我是认真的，我是认真的。我的行李都打包好了。好的。我是说，我加入。我喜欢黄油。我知道你喜欢。而且我喜欢用其他东西雕刻出来的东西，我想。这对我们来说是个很好的搭配。
Mm-hmm.
Well, lady, this is also the episode where we finally gave you your first work birthday.
Yeah.
But your cake was late.
It was a whole thing.
You can listen to it in the episode.
but when we put a call out to our listeners to tell us their favorite moment from the surplus,
we got this letter from Jordan G in Orlando and Angela I had to share.
嗯。好吧，女士，这一集也是我们终于为你举办了第一个工作生日的一集。是的。但你的蛋糕迟到了。那是一整件事。你可以在这一集中听到。但是当我们向听众征集他们最喜欢的盈余时刻时，我们收到了来自奥兰多乔丹·G的这封信，安吉拉，我必须分享一下。
Jordan said,
Hi, ladies, this is more of a response to your episode of the podcast and less about the show itself.
I'm currently listening to the surplus episode for the first time where Angela gets her first work
birthday party.
I just want to say how touching that moment was when Angela was surprised with her cake,
It literally made me tear up.
One of my favorite things about the podcast is being able to have a look into the friendship
between you two.
乔丹说，嗨，女士们，这更多是对你们播客的回应，而不是关于节目本身。我目前正在第一次收听盈余那一集，安吉拉在那里举办了她的第一个工作生日派对。我只想说，当安吉拉收到蛋糕惊喜时，那一刻是多么感人，它真的让我热泪盈眶。关于这个播客，我最喜欢的事情之一就是能够深入了解你们两人之间的友谊。
It is so honest and special, and your obvious connection and love for one another is truly
something so amazing to get to witness.
You make me laugh, cry, and everything in between.
I feel like I'm right there with you.
I'm sure you've heard it a million times, so what's one time more?
Thank you for creating something so special for everyone.
many blessings to both you and your family. Love always, Jordan. Well, Jordan, gosh, that just,
you know what, just completely made my day. Thank you so much. I know. I thought that was so sweet.
它是如此真诚和特别，你们之间明显的联系和对彼此的爱，确实是见证起来如此美妙的事情。你们让我欢笑、哭泣，以及介于两者之间的一切。我觉得我就在你们身边。我相信你们已经听过一百万次了，那再多听一次又何妨？感谢你们为每个人创造了如此特别的东西。祝福你们和你们的家人。永远爱你们，乔丹。好吧，乔丹，天哪，那只是，你知道吗，完全让我的一天变得美好。非常感谢。我知道。我觉得那太贴心了。
And she also had a P.S. I guess I met Jordan in Arizona. At the University of Arizona in 2018,
I had done a book signing for the actor's life. She said, I was literally one of the last people in line
and you still took time to talk with me and sign my book. And as an actor who now,
gets paid full time to perform. Way to go, Jordan. Yes. It was huge encouraging me through those
tough times we all face. Ah, Jordan, yay. Congratulations. Yeah. And thank you for writing in.
Thank you so much, Jordan. Well, I have a letter here from Hannah B in Canada who says,
first off, love you ladies so much. I rewatched the surplus recently and love the scene where Michael
calls in Hank to make the final decision, especially the moment when Hank realized
她还有一个附言。我想我在亚利桑那州见过乔丹。2018年在亚利桑那大学，我为《演员的生活》做过一次签售。她说，我真的是排队最后的人之一，你仍然花时间和我交谈并为我的书签名。作为一名现在全职表演的演员。干得好，乔丹。是的。这对我度过我们都面临的那些艰难时期有很大的鼓励。啊，乔丹，耶。恭喜。是的。谢谢你写信来。非常感谢，乔丹。好吧，我这里有一封来自加拿大汉娜·B的信，她说，首先，非常爱你们，女士们。我最近重温了盈余，喜欢迈克尔叫汉克来做最终决定的那一幕，尤其是汉克意识到那一刻
the power he's been given.
Was it scripted that he would take the jelly beans?
And Michael responds very seriously
that he can take as many as he wants.
Stephen Hughes' energy in this scene is hilarious.
I mean, it is so fantastic.
Hannah, we mentioned in our breakdown
that this is our favorite as well.
他被赋予的权力。他拿走软糖是剧本写的吗？迈克尔非常严肃地回答说他可以拿走他想要的那么多。斯蒂芬·休斯在这一幕中的表现太搞笑了。我是说，这太棒了。汉娜，我们在解析中提到这也是我们最喜欢的一幕。
Oh, yes.
So much.
It's so good.
And Hannah, I went to the script
and it was scripted that Hank
takes some jelly beans,
but that's all it said.
Steve improvised the line, take as many as you want, and Hugh improvised the thank you, thank you,
哦，是的。非常喜欢。太棒了。汉娜，我查了剧本，剧本里确实写了汉克拿了一些软糖，但仅此而已。史蒂夫即兴发挥了那句“拿走你想要的那么多”，休即兴发挥了“谢谢，谢谢”，
before his next scripted line that was, you know, it's nice and warm up here. And I actually think this
little bit that Hannah points out is such a great example of improv on the show, Ang, because we weren't
improvising whole scenes. We would have a scripted bit and then we'd do some little thing and then we'd go
back to scripted and we did it so seamlessly. Yeah, because we had really great writing when there were
these little moments where we could sort of add a little color, we knew right where to do them.
Do you know what I mean? It was just so organic. Yes. Oh, and lady, while I was poking around in the
script looking for the answer to this question, oh my gosh, I found not one, but two cold opens for
this episode. We did not talk about this in our breakdown. Ooh. And this episode does not have a
在他下一句剧本台词之前，你知道，上面又好又暖和。我实际上认为汉娜指出的这一点是节目中即兴表演的一个很好的例子，安吉，因为我们并没有即兴表演整场戏。我们会有一个剧本片段，然后我们会做一些小动作，然后回到剧本，我们做得非常无缝。是的，因为我们有非常棒的剧本，当有这些我们可以增加一点色彩的小时刻时，我们确切地知道在哪里做。你知道我的意思吗？这太自然了。是的。哦，女士，当我在剧本里寻找这个问题的答案时，天哪，我发现了这一集的两个开场白。我们在解析中没有谈到这一点。哦。而且这一集没有
standalone cold open. We just get right into the plot. Oscar just enters Michael's office and tells
him about the surplus. But there were actually two standalone cold opens written for this
episode. I think we only ended up filming one of them. It got added back to the top of the Peacock
Superfan episode. It is a prank that Jim pulls on Dwight. Let's hear it.
What is this thing you just sent me?
Oh, it's really cool.
It's a picture of the most relaxing meadow you've ever seen.
Idiot.
独立的开场白。我们直接进入情节。奥斯卡走进迈克尔的办公室告诉他关于盈余的事。但实际上这一集写了两个独立的开场白。我想我们最终只拍了其中一个。它被加回了孔雀超级粉丝版的顶部。这是吉姆对德怀特搞的一个恶作剧。让我们听听。你刚发给我的这个东西是什么？哦，这真的很酷。这是你见过的最放松的草地的照片。白痴。
I know what this is.
It's supposed to lull me into a sense of calm,
and then a ghoul pops up and scares me.
Why would I do that?
Dwight, of all people I know that you're unscarable.
Damn right, I am.
Oh, hello, relaxing meadow.
I'm so relaxed and calm looking at you right now.
我知道这是什么。它本意是让我陷入一种平静的感觉，然后一个食尸鬼跳出来吓我。我为什么要那样做？德怀特，在所有人中，我知道你是吓不倒的。该死，我是。哦，你好，放松的草地。我现在看着你感到非常放松和冷静。
Oh, no, a scary ghoul just popped up.
I'm so scared, I'm so scared.
Really? Is this the best you could...
Jim?
How are you?
Okay.
That is the best I can do.
He got him.
哦，不，一个可怕的食尸鬼跳出来了。我好害怕，我好害怕。真的吗？这是你能做的最好的……吉姆？你好吗？好的。这是我能做的最好的。他抓到他了。
He got him, lady.
Yeah, so what he does, because you can't see it,
he is right over Dwight's shoulder in a scary mask,
and that is what ends up scaring Dwight.
So that is now at the top of this episode in The Superfan,
but they wrote another cold open for this episode
where Michael and Dwight discover that it's snowing outside.
And we all run outside and have a snow.
他抓到他了，女士。是的，所以他做的是，因为你看不到，他就在德怀特的肩膀后面戴着一个可怕的面具，这就是最终吓到德怀特的原因。所以现在这一集在超级粉丝版中开头就是这个，但他们为这一集写了另一个开场白，迈克尔和德怀特发现外面在下雪。我们都跑出去打雪仗。
But there's not a lot of snow. So the snow is kind of like filled with pebbles. You know when you're like trying to make a snowman, but there's not enough. Yeah. Or snowball or whatever. So you get dirt and sticks and stuff. Yeah. Well, anyway, I bet they're glad they chose this one in the bullpen because then they didn't have to spend a bunch of money on fake snow just to have it get cut from the episode.
That's all I could think of when you shared that. I thought they were going to have to call snow business and get a bunch of fake snow. Yeah, but they do.
didn't. I don't think we shot it. Well, I love a cold open surprise. Well, I also want to talk about
this letter we got from Cassie L. and Milton, Florida. Cassie said, I'm currently watching the
superfan episodes, and there's a scene between Angela and Dwight that has been added back in where
we find out Angela is very passionate about the Mayflower. And it seems that Dwight knows this by his
reaction. So Cassie wants to know, how many times have they had deep conversations about the Mayflower?
This scene made me laugh out loud.
但雪不多。所以雪里有点像充满了鹅卵石。你知道当你试图堆雪人，但雪不够的时候吗？是的。或者雪球什么的。所以你弄到了泥土和树枝之类的东西。是的。好吧，无论如何，我敢打赌他们很高兴在办公区选择了这一个，因为这样他们就不必花一大笔钱买假雪，结果却被从剧集中剪掉了。当你分享那个时，我能想到的就是这些。我以为他们得打电话给雪景公司，弄一大堆假雪。是的，但他们没有。我不认为我们拍了它。好吧，我喜欢开场白的惊喜。好吧，我还想谈谈我们收到的来自佛罗里达州米尔顿的卡西·L的这封信。卡西说，我目前正在看超级粉丝版，安吉拉和德怀特之间有一个被加回来的场景，我们发现安吉拉对五月花号非常热衷。而且从德怀特的反应来看，他似乎知道这一点。所以卡西想知道，他们进行过多少次关于五月花号的深度对话？这一幕让我大笑出声。
I went back and watched it three more times.
Yeah, it was really fun.
And it just, it's one of those scenes, lady, I loved that wasn't in the original, that just shows the history of a couple.
You know, there's all this assumed history that you carry around with you when you are in a relationship with someone and just a window into it is so delicious.
It's like when we got to see Michael and Jan's condo, you know?
I'm like, what?
They've been living this all this time.
But I thought it'd be fun to hear.
我回去又看了三遍。是的，这真的很有趣。这只是，女士，我喜欢那些原版中没有的场景之一，它只是展示了一对情侣的历史。你知道，当你和某人谈恋爱时，你随身携带所有这些假设的历史，而仅仅是窥见它就太美妙了。就像我们看到迈克尔和简的公寓时一样，你知道吗？我当时想，什么？他们一直过着这样的生活。但我认为听听这个会很有趣。
It's after the scene in the kitchen where they are getting the directions to Shrewd Farms,
Angela and Dwight sneak out to the alleyway next to the warehouse.
Let's listen.
I thought you were going to put a muzzle on that singing idiot.
He's not a bad singer.
He is pretty talented, I guess.
And he went to Cornell.
Yeah, well, I provide America with two of its most beloved staples, beads and paper.
那是厨房里他们得到去施鲁特农场的路线后的场景，安吉拉和德怀特溜到了仓库旁边的巷子里。让我们听听。我以为你要给那个唱歌的白痴戴上口套。他唱歌唱得不差。我想他还是很有天赋的。而且他上了康奈尔大学。是的，好吧，我为美国提供了它最受喜爱的两种主食，珠子和纸。
His family is well connected in pockets of Connecticut.
And his ancestors came over on the ma'amination.
Oh, big whoop. Half my family came over on a U-boat and would have destroyed the Mayflower.
Listen to you. Destroyed the Mayflower?
Sorry. I can't believe I said that. Angela.
That's so fun. I so remember doing that scene. You know how some you hear and you're like,
I don't really remember that. I remember saying deep pockets of Connecticut.
It's so good. She's so impressed.
他的家族在康涅狄格州人脉很广。而且他的祖先是乘五月花号来的。哦，大惊小怪。我的一半家人是乘U型潜艇来的，本来会摧毁五月花号。听听你说的。摧毁五月花号？抱歉。我不敢相信我说了那句话。安吉拉。那太有趣了。我非常记得拍那一幕。你知道有些人你听了之后会说，我不记得那个了。我记得说康涅狄格州人脉很广。太棒了。她印象深刻。
I also love that Dwight has to admit he is a good singer.
Yeah. Well, you know what?
What's crazy is that in the background of this scene, lady, there's a little bit of snow on the dumpster.
And you guys are acting like you're really cold.
So I kind of wonder, when did we shoot this?
Was this before or after they decided to bail on that snow cold open?
They were like, we don't know what the cold open is going to be for this episode yet.
So just throw some snow out there so it matches, just in case.
我也喜欢德怀特不得不承认他是个好歌手。是的。好吧，你知道吗？疯狂的是，在这一幕的背景里，女士，垃圾桶上有一点雪。你们表现得好像真的很冷。所以我有点好奇，我们是什么时候拍的？是在他们决定放弃那个雪地开场白之前还是之后？他们当时想，我们还不知道这一集的开场白是什么。所以只要在那儿撒点雪，以防万一。
Just in case.
Okay, everyone, well, thanks so much for sending in your letters about your favorite moments.
We love them.
you can submit your favorites at our website,
OfficeLadies.com.
And now it's time for your second drink of the surplus.
I'm Jenna Fisher.
And I'm Angela Kinsey.
以防万一。好的，各位，非常感谢你们寄来关于你们最喜欢时刻的信。我们很喜欢它们。你们可以在我们的网站OfficeLadies.com提交你们最喜欢的时刻。现在是时候喝第二杯“盈余”了。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。
We were on The Office together.
And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office
Rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office
and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories
that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the Office Ladies.
我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Today is a very special day.
Yes.
It is the last day.
that Angela will be in her 40s.
It is, you guys.
I am 49, staring at 50.
By the time you guys hear this, I'll be 50.
Yeah.
今天是一个非常特别的日子。是的。这是安吉拉40多岁的最后一天。是啊，伙计们。我49岁了，盯着50岁。当你们听到这个的时候，我就50岁了。是的。
That's crazy.
You'll be a hot 50 lady.
Ooh, hot 50.
I was asking you the other day, what does it feel like?
Like, what does 50 feel like as you're approaching this milestone birthday?
I think I've been in denial because I've just been busy with life and kids and whatnot.
But I'm realizing now it feels big.
You know what I mean?
那太疯狂了。你会是一个火辣的50岁女士。哦，火辣的50岁。前几天我问你，感觉如何？就像，当你接近这个里程碑式的生日时，50岁感觉如何？我想我一直处于否认状态，因为我一直忙于生活、孩子之类的。但我现在意识到这感觉很大。你知道我的意思吗？
Like, I realize I'm in a different survey group.
Like, they're like, Americans 18 to 35 surveyed.
Americans, 35 to 45 surveyed.
I'm like, oh, my God, I'm not in the survey anymore.
I'm in the like senior citizens surveyed 50 to 75.
You're going to get surveyed about all like aches and pains and things now, right?
You know what?
My grandmother lived till 100.
就像，我意识到我在一个不同的调查组里。就像他们说，调查18到35岁的美国人。调查35到45岁的美国人。我当时想，天哪，我不在调查范围内了。我在50到75岁的老年人调查里。你现在会被调查关于所有的疼痛和痛苦之类的事情，对吧？你知道吗？我祖母活到了100岁。
And I'll never forget when she was 96.
Her and I were hanging out. She was the best. Her name was Lena Mae. And I said, Grandmother, you're about to turn 97. How does it feel? And she said, well, you know, when I'm sitting down, I feel like I'm 23. It's when I stand up that I feel 97.
Oh, that's amazing. Isn't that amazing? And then she said, nothing's broken, but none of it really works.
So you guys, I'm very excited today because here I am at work, the week of my birthday,
and that means I'm getting a birthday cake, right?
For the first time ever at work?
Sam, do you have it?
Is it hiding?
我永远不会忘记她96岁的时候。我和她在一起。她是最好的。她的名字叫莉娜·梅。我说，祖母，你快要97岁了。感觉如何？她说，嗯，你知道，当我坐着的时候，我觉得我23岁。当我站起来的时候，我才觉得97岁。哦，那太棒了。那不是很神奇吗？然后她说，什么都没坏，但什么都不太好用了。所以伙计们，我今天非常兴奋，因为我在这里工作，在我生日的那一周，这意味着我要得到一个生日蛋糕，对吧？第一次在工作？萨姆，你有吗？它藏起来了吗？
I saw your Arby's bag.
Is it behind it?
Nope.
What?
Angela.
Jenna, you said you had something in your car.
Is this a ruse?
No.
我看到了你的阿比袋子。它在后面吗？没有。什么？安吉拉。珍娜，你说过你的车里有东西。这是个诡计吗？没有。
What was in my car is my son's electric guitar.
that I accidentally brought today.
I thought it was code for cake.
I thought you were going to get cake this whole time.
No, I mean, I can bring you down to the car
and you're going to see a red electric guitar in my trunk.
When I got here, Lee texted me,
and I realized I picked him up from guitar last time,
我车里的是我儿子的电吉他。我今天不小心带了。我以为那是蛋糕的代号。我一直以为你要得到蛋糕。没有，我是说，我可以带你下楼去车里，你会看到我后备箱里有一把红色的电吉他。当我到这里时，李给我发了短信，我意识到我上次接他下吉他课时，
and I never took it out of the trunk.
Oh, my God.
You guys...
Do you want a red electric guitar?
A week of strum, happy birthday on it.
No, I think this is perfect.
I think I need to finish my 40s,
never getting cake on my birthday.
我从来没把它从后备箱里拿出来。天哪。你们……你们想要一把红色的电吉他吗？上面写着“生日快乐”。没有，我觉得这很完美。我觉得我需要结束我的40多岁，生日从来没得到过蛋糕。
But next year, I want a fucking car.
cake. Okay, I'm going to be 50. It's about fucking time. Someone gives me a fucking cake when I'm at work
for my fucking birthday. So 51, do you hear me? Do you hear me? I want a cake. And now I'm looking at
you. Oh, boy. And Cassie, I know you're in there somewhere in the Zoom. I'm 50. This is what
happens when you're 50. You're like, I'm fucking 50. Give me what I want. Okay.
I think we all feel really bad.
I would never want you to feel bad, ever.
Are you messing with me?
但明年，我想要一个该死的蛋糕。好的，我要50岁了。是时候了。当我工作时，有人给我一个该死的蛋糕，为了我该死的生日。所以51岁，你听到了吗？你听到了吗？我想要一个蛋糕。现在我看着你。哦，男孩。还有卡西，我知道你在Zoom里的某个地方。我50岁了。这就是你50岁时会发生的事情。你会像，我该死地50岁了。给我我想要的。好的。我想我们都觉得很糟糕。我永远不会想让你觉得糟糕。你在跟我开玩笑吗？
Lady, I swear it's an electric guitar.
I feel like now...
I mean, you guys, it was really funny.
She was like, I have to run to my car.
I know.
Sam, it's about the guitar.
And I'm like, this is code for cake.
They're messing with me.
女士，我发誓那是把电吉他。我觉得现在……我是说，伙计们，这真的很有趣。她当时说，我得跑去我的车里。我知道。萨姆，是关于吉他的。我当时想，这是蛋糕的代号。他们在捉弄我。
Angela, we officially apologize that there is no cake here.
I am going to see you tomorrow on your actual birthday
to celebrate your actual birthday
where you will be getting a cake.
Yes.
Because I'll be dropping by Gelson's tomorrow tonight to get it.
Because by God, you're getting a cake.
Okay.
安吉拉，我们正式道歉，这里没有蛋糕。我明天会在你真正的生日那天见到你，庆祝你真正的生日，那时你会得到一个蛋糕。是的。因为我今晚会顺便去盖尔森超市买。因为天哪，你会得到一个蛋糕。好的。
All right, done.
This week, we are talking about the surplus.
It is Season 5, Episode 10, written by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg and directed by Paul Feig.
Do you want to hear a fun little tidbit about the title?
Yes.
As you guys know, I am a digital hoarder.
and every once in a while it brings me a real nugget.
好的。好吧，完成了。本周，我们谈论的是盈余。这是第5季第10集，由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编剧，保罗·费格导演。你想听听关于标题的一个有趣的小花絮吗？是的。如你们所知，我是个数字囤积者。偶尔它会给我带来真正的宝贝。
I found an email from Randy Cordray saying that we were tentatively going to be shooting this episode
in October of 2008, end of October.
And the title, the working title was, spend the surplus.
Oh!
Spin the surplus.
And then we just dropped the spend.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
我发现了一封兰迪·科德雷的邮件，说我们暂定在2008年10月，10月底拍摄这一集。标题，暂定标题是，“花掉盈余”。哦！花掉盈余。然后我们只是去掉了“花掉”。嗯。好的。
So as you watch this, know that we're filming end of October 2008.
I went on a website that tells you weather years past.
You guys, the high was 88 degrees.
In October.
And if you watch us shivering outside, know that that's a faky shiver.
Oh, I have some things to say about that when we get there.
Okay.
I'm going to hit you with a summary.
所以当你观看这一集时，要知道我们是在2008年10月底拍摄的。我上了一个告诉你过去几年天气的网站。伙计们，最高气温是88度。在10月。如果你看到我们在外面发抖，要知道那是假装的发抖。哦，当我们讲到那里时，我有一些话要说。好的。我要给你一个总结。
Do it.
Oscar informs Michael there is a $4,300 budget surplus that must be spent today or it gets returned and taken out of next year's budget.
The office is then divided on what to spend it on.
New chairs or a new copier.
This creates tension between Jim and Pam who are on opposing sides.
Pam is team chairs.
Jim is team copier.
Andy and Angela visit Shrewt Farms to discuss their wedding with Dwight.
做吧。奥斯卡通知迈克尔有4300美元的预算盈余，必须在今天花掉，否则它会被退回并从明年的预算中扣除。办公室随后对把钱花在什么地方产生了分歧。新椅子还是新复印机。这在吉姆和帕姆之间造成了紧张，他们站在对立面。帕姆是椅子派。吉姆是复印机派。安迪和安吉拉拜访施鲁特农场与德怀特讨论他们的婚礼。
Michael then learns of a third option for the surplus.
He can return it in exchange for a 15% bonus for himself.
What will he choose?
Well, he doesn't like to make anyone mad, but he also wants the money.
Yeah.
Fast fact number one, the character of Ryan does not appear in this episode.
Good catch.
Yeah. Remember last week he told Kelly he was going to go to Thailand?
迈克尔随后得知了盈余的第三个选择。他可以退回它以换取他自己15%的奖金。他会选择什么？嗯，他不喜欢让任何人发火，但他也想要钱。是的。第一个快讯，瑞安这个角色没有出现在这一集中。好眼力。是的。记得上周他告诉凯利他要去泰国吗？
Well, this marks his first episode on his vacation and he will be gone for 11 weeks because he was filming in glorious bastards, the Quentin Tarantino film.
This was such a big deal for BJ. We were so excited.
He was working with Brad Pitt.
I know.
We really hit him up for Brad Pitt stories and he had nothing.
He just said he was a nice guy.
We're like, come on, give us something.
I know.
好吧，这标志着他度假的第一集，他将离开11周，因为他正在拍摄昆汀·塔伦蒂诺的电影《无耻混蛋》。这对BJ来说是一件大事。我们太兴奋了。他正在和布拉德·皮特合作。我知道。我们真的向他打听布拉德·皮特的故事，但他什么也没说。他只是说他是个好人。我们说，得了吧，给我们讲点什么。我知道。
And then he would drop and do like a one-arm push-up.
BJ, we get it.
You have to get in good shape.
We get it.
Mm-hmm.
Fast fact number two, our cinematographer for this episode, was Matt Sown.
Yeah.
So this actually happened back on business trip because remember, Randall Einhorn, our usual cinematographer, directed business trip.
然后他会趴下做单臂俯卧撑。BJ，我们明白了。你必须保持好身材。我们明白了。嗯。第二个快讯，我们这一集的摄影师是马特·索恩。是的。所以这实际上发生在商务旅行中，因为记得吗，兰德尔·艾恩霍恩，我们通常的摄影师，导演了商务旅行。
So while he was directing Matt Sown, who was normally our B camera operator, stepped in as cinematographer.
But this started a stretch where Matt served as our A camera operator and cinematographer for three weeks while Randall was doing post-production on his episode of business trip.
And so these last three episodes, that's Matt Sown, y'all.
I love that.
Matt Sown was the best.
He is such a hiker.
Do you know that?
Yeah.
所以当他在导演时，通常是我们的B摄像机操作员马特·索恩介入担任摄影师。但这开启了一段时期，马特担任了我们三周的A摄像机操作员和摄影师，而兰德尔正在为他的商务旅行那一集做后期制作。所以最后这三集，那是马特·索恩，伙计们。我喜欢那个。马特·索恩是最棒的。他是个徒步旅行者。你知道吗？是的。
Didn't he and David Dunman used to hike a bunch?
They hike a bunch.
I saw him on a hike one time, and I was like sucking air so hard.
And he like strode past me with his kid in one of those backpack things.
Oh, yeah.
And I was like, shoot, he was really in good shape.
He and Randall both were in good shape.
I know.
他和戴维·邓曼以前不是经常徒步旅行吗？他们经常徒步旅行。我有一次看到他在徒步旅行，我当时喘气喘得太厉害了。他背着孩子，用那种背包，从我身边大步走过。哦，是的。我当时想，天哪，他身材真好。他和兰德尔身材都很好。我知道。
But I mean, they need to be because they're lugging those cameras on their shoulders.
Although now Matt directs.
Yes.
Now he just hikes for pleasure.
Yeah.
Fast fact number three.
a very big portion of this episode takes place at Shrut Farms. And Angela, I know you will have a lot to
share about that. But to kick things off, you have a location breakdown from Randy Cordray.
但我的意思是，他们需要这样，因为他们要把那些摄像机扛在肩上。虽然现在马特导演了。是的。现在他只是为了乐趣而徒步旅行。是的。第三个快讯。这一集很大一部分发生在施鲁特农场。安吉拉，我知道你会有很多关于那个的分享。但首先，你有一个来自兰迪·科德雷的地点解析。
I sure do. You guys, Randy Cordray is the best. Jenna has shared with you emails that he is sent to us.
I reached out to him because I had questions about Shroot Farms. We have shared over the years that there
were a few different locations for Shrewd Farms. And I just wanted to ask Randy, which location
it was, and I had a question about the barn. He responded to my email, Jenna, with so many details,
it was so wonderful, and photos. I'm going to share. Here we go. Are you ready for Randy Cordray's
location breakdown of Shrewd farms? Yes. These scenes were shot in Newhall at the Disney Ranch.
It was originally known as the Golden Oak Ranch. And Jenna, Randy gives us a deep dive
on the origin of the Golden Oak Ranch. Lay it on me. He did a
我当然有。伙计们，兰迪·科德雷是最棒的。珍娜和你分享过他发给我们的邮件。我联系他是因为我对施鲁特农场有疑问。多年来我们分享过施鲁特农场有几个不同的地点。我只是想问兰迪是哪个地点，而且我对谷仓有个疑问。他回复了我的邮件，珍娜，细节非常多，太棒了，还有照片。我要分享。开始了。你准备好听兰迪·科德雷的施鲁特农场地点解析了吗？是的。这些场景是在纽霍尔的迪士尼牧场拍摄的。它最初被称为黄金橡树牧场。而且珍娜，兰迪给了我们关于黄金橡树牧场起源的深度解析。告诉我。他做了一个
deep dive. This is what he said. It was land owned by the famous singing cowboy movie star, Gene Autry.
Gene Autry also owned the California Angels baseball team and the Los Angeles News Station, KTLA,
Channel 5, which was the first TV station on the West Coast. Randy also shared that the Walt Disney
Company purchased the property in 1959 and established a movie location on a still working horse
and cattle ranch, there's more. He shared that just beyond the boundary of the property to the south
in Placarita Canyon State Park is the site of the very first gold discovery in California. In 1842,
a cow hand named Francisco Lopez was sitting under an oak tree and pulled up some wild onions. He found
gold nuggets clinging to the roots. His discovery led to a mini gold rush, six years,
深度解析。他是这么说的。那是著名的歌唱牛仔电影明星吉恩·奥特里拥有的土地。吉恩·奥特里还拥有加州天使棒球队和洛杉矶新闻台KTLA 5频道，这是西海岸第一个电视台。兰迪还分享说，华特迪士尼公司在1959年购买了该房产，并在一个仍在运营的马牛牧场上建立了一个电影拍摄地，还有更多。他分享说，在房产边界以南的普拉卡里塔峡谷州立公园，是加州第一次发现黄金的地点。1842年，一个叫弗朗西斯科·洛佩兹的牧场工人坐在橡树下，拔出了一些野洋葱。他发现金块粘在根上。他的发现导致了一场小型淘金热，比
before the more famous discovery of gold at Sutter's Mill.
Wait, he pulled onions out of the ground and there was gold clinging to, like, the onion
or the root of the onion?
Yeah, gold nuggets clinging to the root of this onion, and it happened right there,
and that is why it's called the Golden Oak Ranch.
It should be called the Golden Onion Ranch.
He was sitting under an oak tree.
It should be called a Golden Oak Onion Ranch.
更著名的萨特磨坊发现黄金早了六年。等等，他从地里拔出洋葱，然后有金子粘在，像洋葱或洋葱根上？是的，金块粘在这个洋葱的根上，它就发生在那里，这就是为什么它被称为黄金橡树牧场。它应该被称为黄金洋葱牧场。他坐在橡树下。它应该被称为黄金橡树洋葱牧场。
Golden Oak Onion Ranch.
Rolls off the tongue.
So there's the background on the origin of the Golden Oak Ranch, which then became the Disney Ranch.
So we spent a lot of time at this Disney Ranch filming this episode.
There's tons more scenes that didn't make it in.
We were there the whole week.
This was weird for me, Jenna, because I was the one not in the office.
And you were there.
黄金橡树洋葱牧场。朗朗上口。所以这就是黄金橡树牧场的背景，后来变成了迪士尼牧场。所以我们花了很多时间在这个迪士尼牧场拍摄这一集。还有很多没放进去的场景。我们在那里待了整整一周。这对我来说很奇怪，珍娜，因为我是那个不在办公室的人。而你在那里。
Yes.
When we shot there, the facilities were just limited to a few buildings, a farmhouse, some barns, and stables.
right? Randy shared with us that in the corner of the ranch, there was a very run-down Western
Street that was really in disrepair, and it was. It looked like a set that had been forgotten about
because no one was making those spaghetti Westerns anymore. It probably had its heyday, but it was
really falling apart. But Randy shared that since then, Disney has invested a ton of money
and has completely modernized the grounds. He said I wouldn't even recognize it. There are six
是的。是的。当我们去那里拍摄时，设施仅限于几栋建筑，一个农舍，一些谷仓和马厩，对吧？兰迪和我们分享说，在牧场的角落里，有一条非常破旧的西部街道，真的年久失修，确实如此。它看起来像一个被遗忘的布景，因为没有人再拍那些意大利西部片了。它可能曾经有过全盛时期，但确实正在分崩离析。但兰迪分享说，从那以后，迪士尼投入了大量资金，并完全现代化了场地。他说我甚至认不出来了。有六个
state-of-the-art sound stages. There's also a fake residential street.
and a business district, and there's a full feature backlot movie location now.
None of that was there when we were there.
It was like a run-down old, like, Western set when we were there.
I've been there because I was there for the bed and breakfast.
Yeah.
When Jim and Pam go to, you know, stay at Shrewd farms.
And there was nothing.
最先进的摄影棚。还有一个假的住宅区街道。和一个商业区，现在有一个完整的电影外景地。当我们去的时候，这些都没有。当我们去的时候，它就像一个破旧的老西部布景。我去过那里，因为我为了住宿加早餐去过。是的。当吉姆和帕姆去，你知道，住在施鲁特农场时。什么都没有。
It was really just these rickety farmhouses and barns that were basically falling apart.
Right.
And there was only a handful of them and then just sort of fields.
Yeah.
Well, now it's a full studio.
Wow.
I know.
I asked him a little bit about the barn we filmed in, and he said the very first scene you see of us walking into the barn, that stable was called the rag-wing barn.
真的只是那些摇摇欲坠的农舍和谷仓，基本上都在分崩离析。对。而且只有少数几个，然后就是一些田野。是的。好吧，现在它是一个完整的摄影棚。哇。我知道。我问了他一点关于我们拍摄的谷仓的事，他说你看到的我们走进谷仓的第一个场景，那个马厩被称为破布翼谷仓。
And Randy negotiated a rate to include the horses and mules and the horse that you see in the stalls.
Oh.
And then the other barn, which was like the fancy barn where Dwight, you know, made it to look like a wedding ceremony.
Yes.
That barn was known as pee-wees because it was the former location.
used in Paul Rubin's Pee Wee's Playhouse.
Oh, wow.
So they all had names.
兰迪协商了一个价格，包括马和骡子，以及你在马厩里看到的马。哦。然后另一个谷仓，就是那个花哨的谷仓，德怀特，你知道，把它弄得像婚礼仪式一样。是的。那个谷仓被称为“皮威”，因为它是以前的地点。用于保罗·鲁本斯的《皮威的游乐场》。哦，哇。所以它们都有名字。
And the actual Shrewt farmhouse was an old farmhouse on the property known as Olivia's.
That's really cool.
I know.
And he sent me pictures of the mules that he took that day.
And he sent me like the map of the location, which it doesn't look anything like that anymore.
It's so wild.
It's completely different.
That's so cool.
而真正的施鲁特农舍是房产上的一座老农舍，被称为奥利维亚家。那真的很酷。我知道。他发给我那天他拍的骡子的照片。他还发给我地图，现在看起来一点也不像那样了。太疯狂了。完全不同。那太酷了。
Thank you, Randy Cordray.
I know.
He's the best.
He really came through.
I know.
Well, listen.
Should we take a break while I run to the store and buy you a cake and you go to the bathroom and we'll be back to break down this episode?
Are you going to go get me a guitar?
谢谢你，兰迪·科德雷。我知道。他是最棒的。他真的做到了。我知道。好吧，听着。我们要不要休息一下，我去商店给你买个蛋糕，你去洗手间，然后我们回来解析这一集？你要去给我买把吉他吗？
Yeah, I'm going to go get the guitar out of my car now.
All right, awesome.
I'm going to need about 20 minutes.
Okay.
We are back and Oscar is presenting Michael with the overall budget for the fiscal year.
And he is trying to explain that they have a surplus of $4,300.
Michael's not quite getting it.
是的，我现在要去把吉他从车里拿出来。好的，太棒了。我需要大约20分钟。好的。好的。我们回来了，奥斯卡正在向迈克尔展示本财年的总预算。他正试图解释他们有4300美元的盈余。迈克尔不太明白。
he says, explain it to me like I'm eight years old.
Then he says, explain it to me like I'm five.
I know.
So Oscar does this great lemonade stand analogy.
Michael seems like he's getting it.
Ultimately, in the end, we're not sure he totally got it.
No.
But Oscar says, you need to spend this money today, and you should really spend it on a new copier.
他说，像对我这个八岁孩子一样解释。然后他说，像对我这个五岁孩子一样解释。我知道。所以奥斯卡做了这个很棒的柠檬水摊类比。迈克尔看起来好像明白了。最终，我们不确定他是否完全明白了。没有。但奥斯卡说，你今天需要花掉这笔钱，你真的应该把它花在买一台新复印机上。
Because we need it.
We desperately need it.
We had a fan question.
from Lauren K. When Oscar is explaining the surplus to Michael and Michael says, explain it to me like
I'm five, there's this great line when Oscar says, then next summer, and Michael says, I'll be six.
That made me laugh so hard. So hard. Lauren wanted to know, was that scripted or was it improvised?
It was scripted. That beat. Steve threw it away so perfectly. It was so cute.
It was so innocent.
因为我们需要它。我们迫切需要它。我们有一个粉丝问题。来自劳伦·K。当奥斯卡向迈克尔解释盈余，迈克尔说，像对我这个五岁孩子一样解释时，奥斯卡说“然后明年夏天”，迈克尔说“我会六岁”。这让我笑得太厉害了。太厉害了。劳伦想知道，那是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的？那是剧本写的。那一拍。史蒂夫把它扔出来得太完美了。太可爱了。太天真了。
I know.
Oh, Michael.
Well, he's very excited.
He knows it's something good, right?
He grasped at least that.
And he's going to announce to the whole bullpen.
Yes.
They've got a surplus.
我知道。哦，迈克尔。好吧，他很兴奋。他知道这是件好事，对吧？他至少抓住了这一点。他要向整个办公区宣布。是的。他们有盈余。
And he thinks maybe we'll get a new copier.
And Pam's like, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, hold up.
We need new chairs.
Toby feels like they really need a good air quality inspection for some of the silent killers.
Here's Toby again.
He's worried about the radon gas.
He's worried about the asbestos.
他想也许我们会得到一台新复印机。帕姆说，不，不，不。等等，等等，停下。我们需要新椅子。托比觉得他们真的需要对一些无声杀手进行一次好的空气质量检查。这是托比。他又在担心氡气了。他在担心石棉。
This is the runner that the writers loved for Toby.
And this is the scene where we realize that Jim is not team chairs.
He wants a copier.
It really made me laugh hard when Creed goes,
The ball's on you, man.
Creed's delivery was so good.
And Jenna, there was a Pam talking head that would have gone here.
And it's about her chair.
这是编剧们为托比设定的跑步者。这一幕我们意识到吉姆不是椅子派。他想要一台复印机。当克里德说“球在你身上，伙计”时，这真的让我大笑。克里德的表达太棒了。珍娜，这里本来有一个帕姆的谈话头。是关于她的椅子的。
and you delivered it from reception.
It's a talking head from reception.
In my chair.
Standing next to your chair.
Oh, what is it?
Sam, play it.
This is the chair that was here when I was hired.
It was crappy then, and it's even worse now.
你从接待处传达的。这是一个来自接待处的谈话头。在我的椅子里。站在你的椅子旁边。哦，是什么？萨姆，播放它。这是我被雇佣时就在这里的椅子。那时它就很烂，现在更糟了。
To give myself a break, sometimes I go outside and sit on the ground.
Oh, yeah, I remember that now.
That's how bad that chair is.
I thought Pam made a really strong argument.
She made me want to be team chair,
because she was like, I make the copies.
I'm the one that has to deal with the copier.
That should tell you how bad these chairs are.
为了让自己休息一下，有时我走到外面坐在地上。哦，是的，我现在记得了。那把椅子有多糟糕。我觉得帕姆提出了一个非常有力的论点。她让我想要成为椅子派，因为她说，我负责复印。我是那个必须处理复印机的人。这应该告诉你这些椅子有多糟糕。
Well, and also, everyone would get a new chair, right?
So it really is something for everyone.
But the other thing I thought was just,
what about the copier in the annex?
There's another copier.
No one wants to walk to the annex.
It's icky back there.
Well, then they should swap them.
嗯，而且，每个人都会得到一把新椅子，对吧？所以这确实是每个人的东西。但我认为另一件事只是，附件里的复印机怎么样？还有另一台复印机。没人想走到附件去。那里很恶心。好吧，那他们应该交换一下。
I know.
Maybe Kelly needs to make a lot of copies.
It feels like there's a simple solution to the copier problem that no one's realizing.
Well, Michael's going to digest all of their ideas and see what comes out the other end.
Coming up at 3 minutes, 56 seconds, is a scene, Jenna, that I didn't think I was going to get through.
I didn't think we would have any usable takes.
Last week, you talked about that clown painting on the wall in Jim's parents' house that you guys could not get through it.
You were laughing.
我知道。也许凯利需要复印很多东西。感觉复印机问题有一个简单的解决方案，没人意识到。好吧，迈克尔要消化他们所有的想法，看看最后会得出什么。在3分56秒，有一个场景，珍娜，我以为我过不去。我以为我们不会有任何可用的镜头。上周，你谈到了吉姆父母家墙上的那个小丑画，你们无法通过它。你们在笑。
Yes.
This scene with Dwight giving directions to Andy and Angela, that was it for me.
Ed and I, we could not get through it.
Like truly, we could not stop laughing.
It's in the bloopers, and I think we got to hear it.
You know, lady, last week I looked at the bloopers to see if I could find any clown painting outtakes.
Yeah.
I couldn't find them, but I did see this.
是的。德怀特给安迪和安吉拉指路的这一幕，对我来说就是这样。埃德和我，我们无法通过它。真的，我们无法停止大笑。它在花絮里，我想我们得听听。你知道吗，女士，上周我看了花絮，看看能不能找到任何小丑画的NG镜头。是的。我没找到，但我看到了这个。
It is so good.
Just, I feel like some of these directions to Shrewd farms are a little weird.
I mean, like, 156 paces from the light red mailbox make a left.
Walk until you hear the beehive and make a right.
If you are attacked by territorial crows.
I have, this is a really easy.
If you smell bear,
pee turned the other way.
太棒了。只是，我觉得去施鲁特农场的一些路线有点奇怪。我是说，像，从浅红色邮箱走156步左转。走到你听到蜂巢的地方右转。如果你被领土乌鸦攻击。我有，这真的很容易。如果你闻到熊尿，转过身去。
I...
If you smell bear pee at any
point, abort, wait in your car
for further instructions. What's the problem
exactly?
The other thing that's so great about this blooper
is that you're hearing all those candy bag
alt directions. Yes, because
我……如果你在任何时候闻到熊尿，中止，在你的车里等待进一步指示。到底有什么问题？这个花絮的另一件伟大的事情是，你听到了所有那些糖果袋的替代路线。是的，因为
in the script, the only directions
were 156 paces
from the light red mailbox and then the one
about the bear. All the rest
are candy bag alts. So were they
just because in the clip you can see that Ed is reading, were they just handing him pieces of paper with like funny directions?
They literally did. They handed him a whole paper that were extra directions. And that's why he was like, I almost had it.
And if you guys watch the bloopers, you'll see that I'm sniffling. I am sniffling because it was so cold on set that day that my nose was running. And I had a tissue in my hand that I was hiding under the table. It was that cold.
在剧本里，唯一的路线是“从浅红色邮箱走156步”，然后是关于熊的那条。其余的都是糖果袋替代品。所以它们只是因为在剪辑中你可以看到埃德在读，他们只是递给他写着有趣路线的纸条吗？他们确实递给了他。他们递给他整张纸，上面有额外的路线。这就是为什么他会说，我差点就成功了。如果你们看花絮，你们会看到我在吸鼻子。我在吸鼻子，因为那天片场太冷了，我的鼻子在流。我手里拿着纸巾，藏在桌子底下。太冷了。
That used to happen to me all the time my nose would run on set.
I know.
I had my sneezing from the allergies and the runny nose from the cold.
Well, I rewatched this scene and all I can see is me sniffling and trying not to laugh.
Well, you laughed a lot.
I did.
Well, Jenna, we had a fan question about this scene.
Allie Joe H wrote in and said, when Angela and Andy are talking to Dwight, Andy says something about a three-way and it looks like Dwight mouth something to Angela.
那以前经常发生在我身上，我的鼻子在片场流个不停。我知道。我有过敏引起的打喷嚏和寒冷引起的流鼻涕。好吧，我重温了这一幕，我能看到的只有我在吸鼻子和试图不笑。好吧，你笑了很多。我确实笑了。好吧，珍娜，我们有一个关于这一幕的粉丝问题。艾莉·乔·H写信说，当安吉拉和安迪在和德怀特说话时，安迪说了关于3P的事，看起来德怀特对安吉拉说了什么。
Do you remember what he said?
I can tell you in the script, Rain had this stage direction.
It says, Dwight rolls his eyes to Angela like,
check out the dummy.
And Angela doesn't give him anything.
So I think Rain was sort of mocking Andy in that moment,
like looking at me like, oh, this guy.
Coming up, we have a scene that was really, really fun for me.
你记得他说了什么吗？我可以告诉你剧本里，雷恩有这个舞台指导。上面写着，德怀特对安吉拉翻了个白眼，好像在说“看看那个傻瓜”。而安吉拉什么也没给他。所以我认为雷恩在那一刻是在嘲笑安迪，就像看着我一样，哦，这家伙。接下来，我们有一个对我来说非常非常有趣的场景。
It's the scene in the kitchen between Pam and Jim,
where Pam is kind of low-key, threatening Jim to be on her side.
Not low key. Full key? Is that an expression?
We had a fan question from Jessica Kay. She would very much like us to discuss Pam's Your on Dangerous Ground moment saying, quote, I was like, damn, Jenna.
Well, Jessica, we came up with this little moment while we rehearsed the scene. So this idea of Pam going over to gym and going in for a kiss but then pulling back, that was something that we,
did in rehearsal. It was not in the script and we just were so tickled. You know those moments when you're
rehearsing a scene or you're doing a scene and you come up with this idea that just opens it up in this new way?
It's so fun. And it's so fun to see everyone else realize it too because I have to imagine that when
这是帕姆和吉姆在厨房里的场景，帕姆有点低调地威胁吉姆站在她这边。不是低调。全调？那是个表达吗？我们有一个来自杰西卡·K的粉丝问题。她非常希望我们讨论帕姆的“你在危险的土地上”时刻，引用说，“我当时想，该死，珍娜。”好吧，杰西卡，我们在排练这一幕时想出了这个小时刻。所以帕姆走到吉姆身边，想要亲吻但又退缩的想法，那是我们排练时做的。剧本里没有，我们只是觉得太好笑了。你知道那些时刻，当你排练一个场景或做一场戏时，你想出了这个以新方式打开它的想法？太有趣了。看到其他人也意识到这一点也太有趣了，因为我必须想象当
Paul Fieg saw it. He was like, oh yes, you have to do that. Yeah. It was really, really cool. And then we knew
we shot this scene first. We were going to mirror it in the tag at the end.
with Jim. Oh, it's so good. And I love Jim's talking head afterward. He was like,
ugh, spooky. You guys were about to head out to Shrewp Farms. There was a deleted driving scene.
It was so good. There's actually two. I'll get to the other one. Wait, there's a scene of you and
Andy and Dwight driving in a car together? Two. Oh, they are bookends. One going there and then one
when we leave. Stop it. Yes. The one on the way there, Dwight and Angela get into a fight.
So Angela's driving.
保罗·费格看到了。他当时就说，哦，是的，你必须得这么做。是的。这真的很酷。然后我们知道我们先拍了这场戏。我们打算在结尾的彩蛋里用吉姆来呼应它。哦，太棒了。而且我很喜欢吉姆之后对着镜头的采访。他说，呃，真诡异。你们当时正准备出发去施鲁特农场。有一个被删减的开车场景。拍得太好了。其实有两个。我会讲到另一个。等等，有一个你、安迪和德怀特一起开车的场景？两个。哦，它们是首尾呼应的。一个是在去那里的路上，另一个是在我们离开的时候。别说了。是的。在去那里的路上，德怀特和安吉拉吵架了。所以是安吉拉在开车。
That tracks for me.
Angela's driving and her car is filthy.
It's like covered in mud.
It's so funny.
Oh.
I know.
Is that because maybe she's been going out to Shrew Farms recently?
Yeah.
这很符合我的预期。安吉拉在开车，她的车脏透了。上面全是泥。太搞笑了。哦。我知道。这是因为她最近经常去施鲁特农场吗？是的。
So she's driving.
Dwight's in the front and Andy's in the back poking his head through.
It's amazing.
For both scenes.
These scenes were so much fun to film.
On the way there, Angela and Dwight are arguing about centerpieces at the reception.
Angela wants a fish bowl with a fish in it.
Dwight's like, let's put a piranha in it and that will kill the fish and there'll be blood.
所以她在开车。德怀特坐在前排，安迪坐在后排，把头探过来。太神奇了。两个场景都是。拍这些戏真的很有趣。在去那里的路上，安吉拉和德怀特在争论接待处的中心装饰品。安吉拉想要一个鱼缸，里面养一条鱼。德怀特说，我们放条食人鱼进去，它会把那条鱼吃了，然后就会有血。
And she's like, I don't want blood on my wedding day.
And then he's like, well, I guess I have to reorder the cake.
Oh, no, that's horrible.
I know.
What is this cake?
And Andy's like, you too.
That is on the DVD.
The other one isn't on the DVD, but I'm going to share it later because it's when they're leaving shrewd farms.
她说，我不想在婚礼当天看到血。然后他说，好吧，看来我得重新订蛋糕了。哦，不，那太可怕了。我知道。这是什么蛋糕？安迪说，你们俩。那段在DVD里。另一个不在DVD里，但我稍后会分享，因为那是他们离开施鲁特农场时的场景。
When Dwight is giving Andy and Angela a tour of shrewd farms, they get into another discussion about, I guess,
On theme with blood, they're talking about the slaughter. Do they really have to slaughter the
entrees on the day of the wedding? Yeah. I mean, yeah. I know. And Andy gets Dwight to not do it the
day of the wedding. And then Andy's like, what's that smell? Oh my gosh, I'm so Southern. Did you hear that?
Smale. What's that smell? It's a vowel before an L. I can't do it. And Angela goes,
manure. Get rid of it. We had a lot of fan questions about the manure. Oh, yeah? Like a lot.
everybody wanted to know, was it real manure? No, it was not. It was made by Phil Shea. That was
Phil Shea's job that day, make faky manure, and he... How did he do it? He mixed mostly oatmeal,
当德怀特带着安迪和安吉拉参观施鲁特农场时，他们又开始讨论，我想，关于血的主题，他们在谈论屠宰。他们真的必须在婚礼当天屠宰主菜吗？是的。我是说，是的。我知道。安迪让德怀特不要在婚礼当天做这件事。然后安迪说，那是什么味道（smell）？天哪，我太南方口音了。你听到了吗？Smale。那是什么味道？L前面有个元音。我发不出来。安吉拉说，粪肥。把它弄走。我们收到了很多关于粪肥的粉丝提问。哦，是吗？很多。每个人都想知道，那是真的粪肥吗？不，不是。那是菲尔·谢做的。那是菲尔·谢那天的工作，制作假粪肥，他……他是怎么做的？他主要混合了燕麦片，
a little bit of sand, and some food coloring. Well, it looks like manure. It does. Good job,
Phil Shea. Lee Eisenberg shared with me that his most vivid memory of shooting this episode
was how hot it was at Shrewt Farms,
and that you guys had to walk around in coats
pretending it was cold.
I noticed my forehead was glistening.
Yeah.
I'm not one to sweat, guys.
一点沙子，还有一些食用色素。嗯，看起来确实像粪肥。确实像。干得好，菲尔·谢。李·艾森伯格告诉我，他拍摄这一集最深刻的记忆是施鲁特农场有多热，而你们必须穿着外套假装很冷。我注意到我的额头在冒汗。是的。我不是那种容易出汗的人，伙计们。
I'm not a big sweater because I'm always cold.
So if it tells you anything about how hot it was, I was sweating.
Also, real random side note,
sorry if this is an overshare,
when we were filming this, I had a five-month-old,
and I would have to go and pump.
You were pumping at Shrewd.
Farnes? I pumped at Shroup Farms. Where? They had like, first of all, our trailers were a little bit of a car right away. Yeah. And they just helped me get there because I would have to go pump. You pumped at Shrute Farms. I pumped at Shrute Farms in the heat. Wow. Things you do for your baby. Back at Dundermifflin, Pam is trying to get Michael on her side with the chairs, but she gets interrupted by Oscar who suddenly wants to go to lunch with Michael. Oh, Oscar knows exactly what he's doing. All Michael.
我不是个爱出汗的人，因为我总是觉得冷。所以如果这能说明当时有多热的话，我当时确实在出汗。另外，一个很随意的题外话，抱歉如果这说得太多了，我们拍这一集的时候，我有一个五个月大的孩子，我必须去挤奶。你在施鲁特农场挤奶？我在施鲁特农场挤奶。在哪？他们有，首先，我们的拖车离得有点远。是的。他们只是帮我过去，因为我必须去挤奶。你在施鲁特农场挤奶。我在酷热的施鲁特农场挤奶。哇。为了孩子你什么都做得出来。回到邓德米夫林，帕姆试图在椅子问题上争取迈克尔的支持，但她被奥斯卡打断了，奥斯卡突然想和迈克尔一起去吃午饭。哦，奥斯卡完全知道自己在做什么。迈克尔
ever once is lunch with the guys and Jim's in on it.
Yeah.
Oh, this is a bold move.
Oh, yeah.
This is Michael's happiest day.
Pam says, it is on.
It is so on.
And then she puts on lipstick and she tossles her hair.
一直想要的只是和伙计们一起吃午饭，而吉姆也参与其中。是的。哦，这是一步险棋。哦，是的。这是迈克尔最开心的一天。帕姆说，开始了。真的开始了。然后她涂上口红，拨弄了一下头发。
What?
What is the outcome of this just to, like, flirt with Michael and make him feel good?
I don't know what she is planning except maybe just.
to look at Michael with some happy eyes to pay attention to him laugh at his jokes.
But Jim, Michael, and Oscar get back from lunch, and they are hysterically laughing.
I mean, they've had the best time.
Yeah.
I mean, how is Pam going to compete with this?
什么？这到底是为了什么，是为了调戏迈克尔让他感觉良好吗？我不知道她在计划什么，除了可能只是。用开心的眼神看着迈克尔，关注他，对他讲的笑话发笑。但是吉姆、迈克尔和奥斯卡从午饭回来时，他们笑得前仰后合。我是说，他们玩得太开心了。是的。我是说，帕姆要怎么和这个竞争？
She tries.
She goes into his office.
She compliments his pants.
She compliments his tie.
Hot tie guy.
And I love how excited Michael is to share that he got his tie for $4 and his pants for $9 at T.J. Max.
她试过了。她走进他的办公室。她称赞他的裤子。她称赞他的领带。性感领带男。性感领带男。性感领带男。我很喜欢迈克尔兴奋地分享他以4美元买到领带，以9美元在T.J. Maxx买到裤子的样子。
Oh, my gosh, that reminds me of my mom.
Does it?
Yes.
So my mom and my sister, they love to go to the outlets at Lake Ozark, Missouri.
All growing up, we would go to this cabin in Lake of the Ozarks in the summer, and they would head out to the outlets.
I'm not a shopper person.
I'm like, I'm going to stay back, I'm going to sit on the dock and read a book.
Oh, I would be hitting those outlets with them.
哦，天哪，这让我想起了我妈妈。是吗？是的。我妈妈和我姐姐，她们喜欢去密苏里州奥扎克湖的奥特莱斯。从小到大，我们夏天都会去奥扎克湖的一个小屋，她们就会去奥特莱斯。我不是个爱逛街的人。我会说，我留在这儿，坐在码头上看书。哦，我会和她们一起去逛那些奥特莱斯。
I know you would.
Especially if there was like one of those pretzel shops and I could get a pretzel while we shop.
Of course there's a pretzel shop.
Of course.
Give me that cinnamon pretzel.
Yes.
So you know how nowadays they have those hall videos where on YouTube where people go shopping and they just take things out of their bag and they show you their hall?
H-A-U-L.
我知道你会的。特别是如果那里有那种椒盐卷饼店，我们逛街时我可以买个椒盐卷饼吃。当然有椒盐卷饼店。当然。给我那个肉桂椒盐卷饼。是的。所以你知道现在YouTube上那些“购物开箱”视频吗，人们去购物，然后从袋子里拿出东西展示他们的战利品？H-A-U-L。
Yeah.
I thought you said, you know those hall videos.
I'm like, why do they film themselves walking down a hall?
That's what I thought.
I thought, who does that?
Are they walking through the hall at the store?
No.
Like, hall.
是的。我以为你说的是，你知道那些大厅（hall）视频。我在想，为什么他们拍自己走在大厅里？我就是这么想的。我想，谁会做那种事？他们是在商店的大厅里走吗？不。是战利品（haul）。
Like, here's my hall.
Here's what I got.
Yes.
They would come home and they would get their stuff out of their bags.
Yeah.
And it was sort of like the hall videos because they would show every item.
But part of the showing of the item would have to include the price.
How much money they saved.
就像，这是我的战利品。这是我买的东西。是的。她们会回家，把东西从袋子里拿出来。是的。这有点像那些战利品视频，因为她们会展示每一件商品。但展示商品的一部分必须包括价格。她们省了多少钱。
So the retail, I got this purse that retails for $44.
I got it for 12.
Yeah.
This shirt, this was 70% off at Ralph Lauren.
I got it for 12 bucks.
Yeah.
So the whole, like, description was always saying the price with the savings.
I think it was a big show for my dad, you know, so that he would feel better about any.
所以零售价，我买的这个钱包零售价是44美元。我只花了12美元买到。是的。这件衬衫，在拉夫劳伦打了7折。我只花了12美元。是的。所以整个描述总是说价格和节省的金额。我想这对我爸爸来说是一场大戏，你知道，这样他会对任何消费感觉好一点。
Well, your dad loves a deal.
He loves a deal.
This is what I know about him.
Oh, yeah.
He wouldn't want my mom to buy a $12 shirt unless she could get it for $7.
That's right.
You know?
So we would always have to make a big show of all the money that was saved.
嗯，你爸爸喜欢捡便宜。他喜欢捡便宜。这是我对他了解的一点。哦，是的。他不会想让我妈妈买一件12美元的衬衫，除非她能以7美元买到。没错。你知道吗？所以我们总是得大张旗鼓地展示省下的所有钱。
Michael's right there with your family.
He sure is.
He could get in on it with my mom and my sister.
Pam really did lay it on thick.
There is a Michael talking head in the script right after all of this, right?
He's been taking a lunch.
Pam has just complimented him.
And it didn't make it in.
迈克尔和你家人是一样的。他确实是。他可以和我妈妈还有我姐姐一起加入。帕姆确实做得太刻意了。剧本里在这一切之后有一个迈克尔的采访，对吧？他刚吃完午饭。帕姆刚称赞过他。但那段没放进去。
And Jenna, I loved it.
Here it is.
Michael's talking head in the script.
When people kiss up to you, it's very easy to get an inflated ego.
You can start to believe the hype that people are saying about you.
I'm not at that point yet, but I'm going to get there.
But I'm going to get there.
That's pretty amazing.
而且珍娜，我很喜欢它。在这里。剧本里迈克尔的采访。当人们拍你马屁时，很容易变得自负。你可能会开始相信人们对你的吹捧。我还没到那个地步，但我会达到的。但我会达到的。那太棒了。
I know.
Back at Shrewd farms, they are inside the farmhouse, and Angela and Dwight are arguing over what kind of butter sculpture she should have at the wedding.
Lady, this scene was so much longer.
it actually started with Andy signing a ton of paperwork because he was actually signing as a witness to the wedding, but he didn't know.
Oh.
Dwight said it was all these insurance forms so that they could get married at Shrewp Farms.
And during this scene, Moes enters.
And there's a really awkward moment with Moes where Angela hises at him.
我知道。回到施鲁特农场，他们在农舍里，安吉拉和德怀特在争论她的婚礼上应该用什么样的黄油雕塑。女士们，这场戏长多了。它实际上是从安迪签署一堆文件开始的，因为他实际上是在作为婚礼证人签字，但他不知道。哦。德怀特说这是所有的保险表格，这样他们才能在施鲁特农场结婚。在这场戏中，莫斯进来了。莫斯有一个非常尴尬的时刻，安吉拉对他发出嘶嘶声。
And then Dwight goes, why do you have to do that?
It's not necessary.
He loves you.
And then Andy's like, how does he love her?
How does he know her?
And then Dwight's like, oh, Moes loves everybody.
He's a people person.
And it's so much longer.
然后德怀特说，你为什么要那样做？没必要。他爱你。然后安迪说，他怎么爱她？他怎么认识她？然后德怀特说，哦，莫斯爱所有人。他是个亲和力强的人。而且这长多了。
And then it ends with us arguing about the butter sculptures.
And once again, we could not get through it.
We were laughing so hard.
It's in the deleted scenes on the DVD.
I'm going to put it in stories, Jenna, because I had to cover my face.
I pull a Mindy.
You can see me laughing with my hands over my face.
But yes, then they get into this ridiculous argument about this sculpture.
然后以我们争论黄油雕塑结束。再一次，我们没法演完。我们笑得太厉害了。它在DVD的删减片段里。我会把它发到故事里，珍娜，因为我不得不捂住脸。我学了明迪。你可以看到我笑着把手捂在脸上。但是的，然后他们陷入了关于这个雕塑的荒谬争论。
and that's what made it in the actual episode.
We got a fan question from Gabriella T.
Who said, Angela tells Dwight she wants a cat sculpture made out of cow butter for her wedding.
I am from Iowa.
And every year at the Iowa State Fair, there is a cow butter sculpture on display.
The very first cow butter was sculpted in 1911, and it has grown to be a famous tradition at the Iowa State Fair.
Love it.
I did a deep dive on cow butter sculptures.
这就是最终出现在正片里的内容。我们收到了加布里埃拉·T的粉丝提问。她说，安吉拉告诉德怀特她想要一个用牛黄油做的猫雕塑作为婚礼装饰。我来自爱荷华州。每年在爱荷华州博览会上，都有一个牛黄油雕塑在展出。第一个牛黄油雕塑是在1911年雕刻的，它已经成为爱荷华州博览会的一个著名传统。太喜欢了。我深入研究了牛黄油雕塑。
I want to hear it.
All right.
So at the Iowa State Fair, every year they make a life-size cow out of butter.
A whole cow?
Yeah.
That's huge.
It starts with a frame of wood, metal, wire, and steel mesh.
我想听听。好的。所以在爱荷华州博览会上，他们每年都会用黄油制作一头真人大小的牛。整头牛？是的。那太大了。是的。它从木头、金属、铁丝和钢网的框架开始。
Okay.
And then they add 600 pounds of low moisture, pure cream, Iowa butter.
It sits in a 40-degree cooler, and then layers of butter are.
applied until it is full-sized. It measures five and a half feet high and eight feet long.
What? Yeah. I saw pictures. It's a cow, but it's butter. I need to see the picture.
I'll send it to you. So a real dairy cow weighs like a thousand pounds. The butter version
weighs about 600 pounds. Wow. This butter cow could butter about 19,200 pieces.
of toast. And this part I'm unsure about, but every year, most of the butter from the butter cow
好的。然后他们加上600磅低水分、纯奶油的爱荷华黄油。它放在一个40度的冷藏室里，然后一层一层地涂上黄油，直到它变成全尺寸。它高五英尺半，长八英尺。什么？是的。我看了照片。它是头牛，但它是黄油做的。我得看看照片。我会发给你。所以一头真正的奶牛重约一千磅。黄油版本重约600磅。哇。这头黄油牛可以涂抹大约19,200片吐司。这一部分我不确定，但每年，大部分来自黄油牛的黄油
is recycled and it can be used for up to 10 years. I hope so. That's a lot of butter. It is.
Would you not use the recycled cow sculpture butter? Well, I mean, they don't know. Five second
rule. Kind of. Not really. They also do a companion butter sculpture every year.
to the cow? The cow has a buddy? Yes. That stands next to it? Correct. What is it? Well, one year it was Elvis
Presley. What? A butter Elvis. Elvis? Made out of butter. Oh my gosh. Another year it was Harry Potter.
Oh, get out. Another year, they did Star Trek. And in 2018, they did a celebration of the 100th
anniversary of John Deere. Was there a tractor? Yes. Oh, my dad would have loved that. They did
a replica of the Waterloo boy tractor. I took a picture and it's a tractor out of butter next to the cow.
会被回收，可以使用长达10年。我希望如此。那可是很多黄油。确实。你不会用回收的牛雕塑黄油吗？嗯，我是说，他们不知道。五秒规则。算是吧。也不完全是。他们每年还会做一个配套的黄油雕塑。和牛一起？牛还有个伙伴？是的。站在它旁边？没错。是什么？嗯，有一年是猫王。什么？黄油猫王。猫王？用黄油做的。哦，天哪。还有一年是哈利·波特。哦，别说了。还有一年，他们做了《星际迷航》。2018年，他们庆祝了约翰迪尔成立100周年。有拖拉机吗？是的。哦，我爸爸会喜欢的。他们做了沃特卢男孩拖拉机的复制品。我拍了照片，那是牛旁边的一个黄油拖拉机。
Wow. I wonder if you could climb up in it. Probably not. Well, I'm not eating that recycled butter.
Sorry to interrupt you guys. I got to catch, I caught one thing from the start of the podcast. Hold on real quick.
Oh, no. It's got to fix it. Okay. No, it's fine. Just give me one second. I can, I can repair it.
Okay.
Hold on.
Please.
All right, Angela. How do you feel? This is your first.
work birthday. You guys so got me. You so got me. I was so surprised. I really thought when I got here that
哇。我想知道你能不能爬上去。可能不行。好吧，我可不吃那种回收黄油。抱歉打断你们。我得抓，我从播客开始就抓到一个点。等等，很快。哦，不。得修好它。好的。不，没关系。给我一秒钟。我能，我能修好它。好的。等等。拜托。好的，安吉拉。你感觉如何？这是你的第一个工作生日。你们真的抓到我了。你们真的抓到我了。我太惊讶了。我真的以为我到这里的时候
the guitar was code for cake. And then when it wasn't, I was like, oh, well, maybe they've just all been
busy and, oh, okay. I feel bad I went off on that rant. Well, what happened, Angela,
was that we were going to surprise you at the top of the podcast with a cookie-puss cake.
A Carvel cookie-puss cake? Yes. But there was a problem that happened.
and the cake got lost in transit.
Poor Cassie has been hiding out here since like 9.30 this morning waiting for this cake delivery.
Poor Cassie, by the way, this is the first time we've all been in person, and it's amazing to see you.
Cassie, say hi to everyone.
吉他是蛋糕的暗号。然后当它不是的时候，我想，哦，好吧，也许他们只是都很忙，哦，好吧。我为刚才的抱怨感到抱歉。嗯，发生了什么，安吉拉，我们本来打算在播客开始时用一个Cookie-Puss蛋糕给你惊喜。一个Carvel Cookie-Puss蛋糕？是的。但出了个问题，蛋糕在运输途中丢了。可怜的凯西从今天早上9点半就一直躲在这里等这个蛋糕送达。可怜的凯西，顺便说一句，这是我们第一次全员到齐，见到你真是太棒了。凯西，和大家打个招呼。
Hey, everybody.
Yay!
Well, I saw a few times you had to check your phone and text, but I thought it was all about the guitar.
No, it was a panic thread about your cake.
Oh, no.
And then you called us out, and we were like, no, but we had a cake and it's jimba.
And also, Cassie put together this amazing board for you.
嘿，大家好。耶！耶！嗯，我看到几次你不得不看手机发短信，但我以为那都是关于吉他的。不，那是一个关于你蛋糕的恐慌群聊。哦，不。然后你叫我们，我们说，不，但我们有个蛋糕，是吉姆巴。而且，凯西为你准备了这个很棒的板子。
It is all of these cards that people sent in because they heard that you did not get your birthday celebrated properly.
And so people from the office ladies' Facebook page sent you cards.
That is so sweet.
They know because I was real chatty that I never had a cake at work or at school.
You guys, that is so lovely.
Well, we could not let you start your 50s without a proper work birthday.
Thank you guys so much.
这是人们寄来的所有卡片，因为他们听说你没有好好庆祝生日。所以办公室女士Facebook页面的粉丝们给你寄了卡片。那太贴心了。那太贴心了。他们知道，因为我真的很爱唠叨，我从来没在工作或学校里吃过蛋糕。你们，那太可爱了。嗯，我们不能让你在没有一个像样的工作生日的情况下进入50岁。非常感谢你们。
I love every single second.
I was truly surprised.
And I cannot wait to read all of these cards that you guys sent in.
It's so lovely.
I'm going to sit down and read every single one.
And thank you for my cake at Cake End.
It happened.
我爱每一秒。我真的感到很惊讶。我迫不及待地想读你们寄来的所有这些卡片。太可爱了。我要坐下来读每一张。谢谢你们给我的蛋糕，在蛋糕环节。它发生了。它发生了。
Oh, my gosh.
Well, before we did your birthday, we were talking about butter sculpture.
I know. It's really hard you guys. Now I'm like, okay, we got to work. We still have work to do. I know.
We were talking about cat butter sculptures.
And y'all, I googled cat butter sculptures.
And let me tell you, it does not disappoint.
Google image cat butter sculptures.
Can I tell you the very first one that came up?
哦，天哪。嗯，在我们庆祝你的生日之前，我们在谈论黄油雕塑。我知道。这真的很难，伙计们。现在我在想，好吧，我们得工作了。我们还有工作要做。我知道。我们在谈论猫黄油雕塑。你们，我谷歌了猫黄油雕塑。让我告诉你们，它没有让人失望。谷歌图片搜索“猫黄油雕塑”。我能告诉你第一个跳出来的是什么吗？
Yeah.
I'm going to show it to you.
I'm going to put it in stories.
How do I describe this to you guys?
This is the first one that came up for me.
There's more than one.
It is a cat made out of butter, pooping butter pooping butter poop.
next to a block of butter.
好的。我要展示给你看。我会把它发到故事里。我该怎么向你们描述这个？这是第一个跳出来的。不止一个。那是一只用黄油做的猫，在拉黄油屎，旁边是一块黄油。
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I guess it's a thing.
There was more than one by different people.
What's that about?
I don't know.
I have to think this is not the cat butter sculpture, Angela Martin would want.
There's also some majestic cats out there made of butter.
It was amazing.
哦，天哪。是的，我想这是一种潮流。有不止一个人做了这个。这是怎么回事？我不知道。我得认为这不是安吉拉·马丁想要的猫黄油雕塑。外面也有一些用黄油做的威严的猫。太神奇了。
People do really weird things with butter.
They do weird things with cats.
There's the whole litter box birthday cake.
Have you seen those?
Yes.
Where it's a cake and it looks like litter and then you make like tutsy.
rolls into poops?
Yeah.
人们用黄油做真的很奇怪的事情。他们对猫做奇怪的事情。还有整个猫砂盆生日蛋糕。你们见过吗？是的。就是一个蛋糕，看起来像猫砂，然后你把图西卷糖做成屎的样子？是的。
For the cat lover in your life.
Put that next to the butter, cat pooping butter.
Happy birthday.
Next year.
That's it.
That's my cake next year.
I want the cat litter box cake.
为你生活中的爱猫人士准备的。把它放在那个拉黄油屎的猫旁边。生日快乐。明年。明年。就是这样。那是明年的蛋糕。我想要猫砂盆蛋糕。
All right.
There was also a deleted Andy talking head after the scene because this would have been
if you're keeping manure count, the second pile of manure he steps in.
Yes.
It's really funny.
You guys, he's outside by the barn, hosing off his show.
and he's sobbing and he says, this just isn't how I imagined it.
There's just so much shit.
好的。在那场戏之后还有一个被删减的安迪采访，因为如果你在统计粪肥数量的话，这是他踩到的第二堆粪肥。是的。真的很有趣。你们，他在谷仓外面，用水管冲洗他的鞋子，他在啜泣，他说，这根本不是我想象的那样。这里有太多的屎了。
It was really funny.
That is on the DVD.
Oh, back at the office, Jim is watching Pam struggle with the copier.
Everyone's really laying it on thick with Michael.
They're making him hot chocolate.
They're opening doors for him.
It's the best day of his life.
It really is.
真的很有趣。那在DVD里。哦，回到办公室，吉姆看着帕姆在复印机前挣扎。每个人都对迈克尔太刻意了。他们给他做热巧克力。他们为他开门。这是他一生中最美好的一天。确实是。
We had a fan question from Stephanie M.
At 10 minutes, 25 seconds, Michael walks into his office and off camera, we hear him say, I almost choked.
Was that a line that was scripted?
Or did Steve Correll actually almost choke on his drink?
It was neither.
It was an improvisation.
He's doing that as Michael.
He was not choking.
我们收到了斯蒂芬妮·M的粉丝提问。在10分25秒，迈克尔走进他的办公室，在镜头外，我们听到他说，我差点噎死。那是剧本里的台词吗？还是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔真的差点被饮料噎住？都不是。那是即兴表演。他作为迈克尔在做那个动作。他没有噎住。
He's going to choke later on some tiramisu powder.
It's the funniest choking scene I've ever seen.
Ever seen.
I want to study.
I want to study it.
I so believed it.
At first, I thought, was that scripted?
I had to go look.
他稍后会因为提拉米苏粉噎住。那是我见过最有趣的噎住场景。见过。我想研究。我想研究它。我太相信了。起初，我想，那是剧本写的吗？我不得不去查。
I had to look, too.
It was so brilliant.
And then he did that thing, and we're jumping ahead, you guys.
But after two bites that were failed attempts, because he's choking, he goes for a third.
And then with his hands, he's like, no, no.
Yeah, he has to stop himself.
So good.
Dwight is going to take Angela to a new barn.
我也得查。太精彩了。然后他做了那个动作，我们跳得太快了，伙计们。但在两次失败的尝试后，因为他在噎住，他尝试了第三次。然后用他的手，他就像，不，不。是的，他不得不阻止自己。太棒了。德怀特要带安吉拉去一个新的谷仓。
Mm-hmm.
It's beautiful.
It's gorgeous.
He's decorated it, like, how.
it will be on her wedding day with chairs and sparkly lights. Yeah. And Andy's like,
Hey, because he's happy too. Yeah, there's a priest. And no manure. It's perfect.
Dwight is going to suggest that they sort of roleplayed the ceremony. He wants Andy to get a bird's
eye view. So he says, you know, you walk her down as if you're her father and she'll marry me.
嗯。很美。太华丽了。他装饰了它，就像婚礼当天那样，有椅子和闪烁的灯光。是的。安迪说，嘿，因为他也很快乐。是的，有个牧师。没有粪肥。太完美了。德怀特建议他们演练一下仪式。他想让安迪从旁观者的角度看。所以他说，你知道，你带她走过来，就像你是她的父亲，她会嫁给我。
But, you know, so you can see what it looks like. Yes. And, you know, the priest doesn't speak any English.
He only speaks German, so they don't know what he's saying.
In the script, it says Angela Martin is moved to tears by this moment.
I think because it is really playing out what's in her true heart, which would be what it would be like to marry Dwight.
Yeah.
We had a fan question from L.E.B.
In the scene where Dwight and Angela are getting married at Shreve Farms, is the minister actually speaking German?
Yes.
但是，你知道，这样你可以看到它看起来是什么样。是的。而且，你知道，牧师不会说英语。他只会说德语，所以他们不知道他在说什么。在剧本里，写着安吉拉·马丁被这一刻感动得流泪。我想是因为这真的演出了她内心深处的东西，也就是嫁给德怀特会是什么样子。是的。我们收到了L.E.B的粉丝提问。在德怀特和安吉拉在施鲁特农场结婚的场景中，牧师真的在说德语吗？是的。
All of the German in this scene is accurate.
the actor who played the priest was posth boyd, and he was cast because he was fluent in German.
Mm-hmm.
And also because he was comfortable riding horses.
Yes, because he rides a horse at the end.
Randy said that the actor arrived early to set that day so that he could select one of the horses and practice on it.
Mm-hmm.
Randy also said that they had to submit a translated version of the priest's script to the NBC legal department of standards and practices.
这一幕中所有的德语都是准确的。扮演牧师的演员是波斯·博伊德，他被选中是因为他精通德语。嗯。而且因为他骑马很自在。是的，因为他在最后骑了一匹马。兰迪说那位演员那天很早就到了片场，这样他就可以挑选一匹马并练习。嗯。兰迪还说，他们必须向NBC法律部门的标准和实践部门提交牧师剧本的翻译版本。
because we had to prove that we weren't trying to sneak in any dialogue that would be considered unacceptable to the censors.
It feels like they didn't trust us.
I wonder why.
Well, here is the translation.
The priest is saying,
Groom and bride,
you come here voluntarily with hearts prepared to receive each other in marriage?
Will you love each other,
因为我们必须证明我们没有试图偷偷加入任何会被审查员认为不可接受的对话。感觉他们不信任我们。我想知道为什么。嗯，这是翻译。牧师在说，新郎和新娘，你们是自愿来到这里，怀着准备好在婚姻中接纳彼此的心吗？你们会彼此相爱，
respect, and be loyal to one another until death separates you?
Are you ready to fulfill?
your obligation to raise your children as Christian parents should. So that is what Dwight and
Angela are agreeing to in their marriage vows. I guess Dwight is going to forego standing in his own
grave to marry her just so he can make it happen. Yes, because that is truly the shrewd tradition.
And would tip off Andy. This whole thing is going to lead into Angela getting pretty sentimental.
Yeah, and she realizes I made a mistake with Andy.
She says she made a mistake.
尊重，并对彼此忠诚，直到死亡将你们分开吗？你们准备好履行你们作为基督徒父母应尽的抚养孩子的义务了吗？这就是德怀特和安吉拉在结婚誓言中同意的内容。我想德怀特为了娶她，宁愿放弃站在自己的坟墓里，只是为了让这件事发生。是的，因为那才是真正的施鲁特传统。这会给安迪提个醒。这一切都会导致安吉拉变得相当多愁善感。是的，她意识到我选错了安迪。她说她犯了个错误。
I know.
She tells Dwight.
I picked the wrong guy.
Dwight, man, he just messed it up.
He does because he gets real arrogant.
He's like, I know, and I took care of it.
I fixed it.
And he sneakily had them married without her consent.
我知道。她告诉德怀特。我选错了人。德怀特，伙计，他搞砸了。他确实搞砸了，因为他变得非常傲慢。他说，我知道，我处理好了。我解决了。他偷偷地在没有她同意的情况下让他们结婚了。
And she does not like that and does not appreciate it.
No.
He almost had her back in that moment.
Yep.
But no.
No.
She's furious with him that he was.
would do such a huge life moment in this sneaky way. We got a fan question from Rebecca M.
她不喜欢那样，也不领情。不。在那一刻他差点挽回了她。是的。但没有。不。她对他会用这种偷偷摸摸的方式完成如此重大的人生时刻感到愤怒。我们收到了丽贝卡·M的粉丝提问。
Does Dwight's secret marriage actually count in the state of Pennsylvania? Or did the writers make
this up? Good question. Well, Pennsylvania is actually one of the only states where you can do something
called self-unite. So Colorado also allows this. According to the American Civil Liberties Union
of Pennsylvania, the tradition of self-uniting in marriage dates back to 1681. It has its roots in the
state's Quaker population. And because the religious sect does not have any ministers,
members of the Quaker faith traditionally self-unite in marriage. So these are often referred to as
Quaker licenses, but self-uniting licenses do not require the applicants to practice any specific
religion or any religion at all. So under Pennsylvania marriage law, couples wishing to marry without
德怀特的秘密婚姻在宾夕法尼亚州真的算数吗？还是编剧编出来的？好问题。嗯，宾夕法尼亚州实际上是少数几个可以进行所谓“自我结合”的州之一。科罗拉多州也允许这样做。根据宾夕法尼亚州美国公民自由联盟的说法，自我结合婚姻的传统可以追溯到1681年。它植根于该州的贵格会群体。由于该宗教派别没有任何牧师，贵格会信仰的成员传统上在婚姻中自我结合。所以这些通常被称为贵格会许可证，但自我结合许可证不需要申请人信奉任何特定宗教，甚至不需要信奉任何宗教。因此，根据宾夕法尼亚州的婚姻法，希望在没有
an officiant can obtain a self-uniting license. They can perform their own ceremony. The only rule is
there have to be at least two witnesses who are required to sign the document. Which Angela and Andy
signed this insurance document and I guess the priest would have signed something. Yes. In this scenario,
the priest and Andy were the witnesses.
So, this marriage was legal.
How about that?
This would have led to a delicious, deleted car ride home scene.
Lady, it's a rough one.
主持人的情况下结婚的夫妇可以获得自我结合许可证。他们可以举行自己的仪式。唯一的规则是必须至少有两名证人签署文件。安吉拉和安迪签署了这份保险文件，我想牧师也会签署什么。是的。在这种情况下，牧师和安迪是证人。所以，这段婚姻是合法的。怎么样？这本来会引出一个美味的、被删减的开车回家场景。女士们，那是一段艰难的旅程。
It's right up there with a Jan Michael car ride home.
All right?
This was in the shooting script.
It's not on the DVD.
It's out there somewhere in the world, you guys.
It was so amazing.
Angela is driving home, furious.
Dwight's in the front passenger seat.
它和简·迈克尔开车回家的场景不相上下。好吗？这在拍摄剧本里。它不在DVD上。它在世界上的某个地方，伙计们。太神奇了。安吉拉开车回家，怒气冲冲。德怀特坐在前排乘客座位上。
Andy is in the back, leaning between the two of them.
And they start out the car ride, and Andy's like, we did it!
He's so happy, and he starts singing at the top of his lungs, this song.
That's what he's singing in the back seat.
That exact part of the song is in the script.
What you just heard is four non-blonds.
And Angela is so annoyed that Andy is singing, so she turns off the
radio and Andy keeps singing and comes in with this part. That sounds like Andy to me. Right? Yeah. In the script,
安迪坐在后排，探身在他们两人之间。他们开始开车，安迪说，我们做到了！他太高兴了，开始大声唱这首歌。他在后座唱的就是那部分。歌的那一部分就在剧本里。你刚才听到的是“四非金发女郎”（Four Non Blondes）。安吉拉对安迪唱歌感到非常恼火，所以她关掉了收音机，安迪继续唱，并唱到了这一部分。这听起来很像安迪。对吧？是的。在剧本里，
it says Angela looks like she might drive the car into a tree. Dwight is stealing glances at Angela.
Andy, oblivious, is singing for nonblots. Wow. How did you get through that with Ed singing in the
back seat, though? How did you keep a straight face? I'm telling you, we laughed through this whole episode.
Every single thing was funny to me. This next scene is the one that I could not.
get through. I don't know how you did. It's one of my favorite scenes of the whole episode. It's one of my
favorite scenes of the whole series. Yes, it's my favorite Hank scene. Oh, yeah. So Michael, who can't
make a decision, has decided to call Hank from security. Yeah. Who, as he explains, hustled up the
stairs because he thought it was an actual emergency. Well, you know, Michael texts people 911 to get their
写着安吉拉看起来好像要把车开进树里。德怀特偷偷瞥向安吉拉。安迪，毫无察觉，在唱“四非金发女郎”。哇。不过，当埃德在后座唱歌时，你是怎么熬过去的？你是怎么忍住不笑的？我告诉你，我们整集都在笑。每一件事对我来说都很有趣。下一场戏是我没法演完的。我不知道你是怎么做到的。这是我整集最喜欢的场景之一。这是我整个系列最喜欢的场景之一。是的，这是我最喜欢的汉克场景。哦，是的。所以迈克尔，无法做决定，决定打电话给保安汉克。是的。他解释说，他匆忙跑上楼，因为他以为是真正的紧急情况。嗯，你知道，迈克尔给人们发911短信来引起他们的
retention. So Hank arrives, and I just want to say this was one of those scenes that was set at the
reception desk, and I'm in the shot, and I wanted to edge myself out of the shot because I was
ruining it because I was laughing. From the minute Hugh walks in, the minute he takes a few of the
candies and starts eating them, I was like, I wouldn't make it. That was an improvisation,
and the first time he did it, I laughed. Because it was so brilliant. It's so,
Brilliant.
So Michael is going to ask Hank, what do we do?
He makes a big announcement.
注意。所以汉克到了，我只想说这是在接待处拍摄的场景之一，我在镜头里，我想把自己挤出镜头，因为我笑场了，毁了它。从休进来的那一刻起，他拿了一些糖果开始吃的那一刻起，我就想，我做不到。那是即兴表演，他第一次做的时候，我笑了。因为它太精彩了。太精彩了。所以迈克尔要问汉克，我们该怎么办？他做了一个大声明。
He's like, listen, Hank is going to decide.
Yeah.
And Hank's like, can I see the copier?
Opens up doors and stuff, looks at it.
And he's like, now let me see the chair.
And the room is riveted.
They're hanging on his every word.
他说，听着，汉克来决定。是的。汉克说，我能看看复印机吗？是的。打开门之类的，看着它。然后他说，现在让我看看椅子。房间里的人都被吸引住了。他们全神贯注于他的每一个字。
But the scene ends amazing.
My favorite is the ending of the scene.
My favorite.
Well, first of all, he's sort of like.
He, like, explains his theory why the office would need both.
There's new copiers.
They're amazing.
Yeah.
但场景结尾太棒了。我最喜欢的是场景的结尾。我最喜欢的。嗯，首先，他有点像。他解释了他的理论，为什么办公室需要两者。有新的复印机。它们很棒。是的。
Although those chairs, he could not sit in.
Yes.
And Michael's like, so?
And everyone's waiting.
And he goes, let me look at the cop here again.
Michael's like, get out.
Get out.
虽然那些椅子，他坐不进去。是的。迈克尔说，所以呢？每个人都在等。他说，让我再看看复印机。迈克尔说，出去。出去。出去。
It's so funny.
Angela, this was the first time for office ladies that I have watched the show with my kids.
Oh, really?
Yes.
Oh, I watch them all the time with my kids.
I know.
太搞笑了。安吉拉，这是《办公室女士》第一次我和我的孩子们一起看这部剧。哦，真的吗？是的。哦，我经常和我的孩子们一起看。我知道。我知道。我知道。
I know, I know.
It was a pinch, and I said, guys, I have to watch this.
I have to watch it.
You can watch it with me or you can go outside and scooter or something.
So I turned it on.
First of all, my son was just giggling through the whole thing.
He's a little older, so I think he got more of the humor.
我知道。我知道，我知道。这是一个紧要关头，我说，伙计们，我得看这个。我得看它。你们可以和我一起看，或者你们可以去外面滑滑板车什么的。所以我打开了它。首先，我儿子一直在咯咯笑。他大一点，所以我认为他理解了更多的幽默。
The humor, yeah.
But this moment when he says, let me see the copier again.
And Michael said, get out.
They were dying.
And then they started doing it as a bit.
That is so good.
It was so fun.
Gosh, I'm so excited as my kids get older for them to discover it.
幽默，是的。但当他说，让我再看看复印机时。迈克尔说，出去。他们笑死了。然后他们开始把它当作一个梗。太棒了。太有趣了。天哪，我太兴奋了，随着我的孩子们长大，他们会发现它。
Yeah.
I know.
Well, my kids love The Office, and, you know, every once in a while we'll watch an episode, and Isabel will go, Mom, because Angel Martin is so mean.
And you know, Jack, my stepson loves Office Ladies.
I know.
Whenever I see him, he'll tell me some fun thing he heard on Office Ladies, which I love.
He was like, I'm so excited that you guys are going to talk to Stephen Merchant.
是的。我知道。嗯，我的孩子们喜欢《办公室》，你知道，偶尔我们会看一集，伊莎贝尔会说，妈妈，因为安吉拉·马丁太刻薄了。你知道，杰克，我的继子喜欢《办公室女士》。我知道。每当我见到他，他都会告诉我他在《办公室女士》里听到的一些有趣的事情，我很喜欢。我知道。他说，我太兴奋了，你们要和斯蒂芬·莫昌特谈话。
I love that they watched it with you.
So we kind of already talked about this scene where Michael is eating tiramisu while talking to David Wallace.
But what we did not mention is that David gives him some new information.
Yeah.
He's like any boss that comes in under budget gets 15% of that surplus.
Michael whips out his calculator and he discovers that means he could get $645.
Do you know how far that can go at Burlington?
Ten Co Factory? You're literally a king if you walk in there with $645. Well, Michael's got dollar
我喜欢他们和你一起看。所以我们已经谈过了迈克尔一边和戴维·华莱士说话一边吃提拉米苏的场景。但我们没有提到的是，戴维给了他一些新信息。是的。他说任何预算有盈余的老板都能得到盈余的15%。迈克尔拿出计算器，发现这意味着他能得到645美元。你知道在伯灵顿（Burlington）那能买多少东西吗？十个工厂店？如果你带着645美元走进去，你简直就是国王。嗯，迈克尔现在脑子里全是
signs now on the brain. Michael walks out of his office and he announces that he doesn't think
they need a new copier or new chairs. He demonstrates that the copier works perfectly and then he's
going to demonstrate how great Pam's chair really is. Two things. First of all, in the bloopers,
Jenna, when Steve tries to use the copier, that copier actually...
actually was really crappy. It was awful. It was really old and crappy and half the time would not work
in real life. When we needed it to. When we needed it to. And it would eat paper. It would like make
noises. And he says, this copier works fine. And he hits the button. And in real life, it went,
and you guys all started laughing. It was so funny. Paul Fieg sent us an audio clip because this was
美元符号。迈克尔走出办公室，宣布他认为他们不需要新复印机或新椅子。他演示了复印机工作得很好，然后他要演示帕姆的椅子到底有多好。两件事。首先，在花絮里，珍娜，当史蒂夫试图使用复印机时，那台复印机实际上……真的很烂。它太糟糕了。它真的很旧很烂，现实生活中有一半时间都不能用。当我们需要它的时候。当我们需要它的时候。它会吃纸。它会发出噪音。他说，这台复印机工作正常。他按下按钮。在现实生活中，它发出声音，你们都开始笑了。太搞笑了。保罗·费格给我们发了一个音频片段，因为这是
one of his favorite memories from shooting this episode. Here's what he had to say. There was so many
fun things in season five, but weirdly, one of my favorite episodes that we did was the surplus.
And it's an episode that people don't talk about as much. And I just think it's got some of the
funniest stuff in it. I think I laughed harder during that. My favorite gag, one of my favorite
gags that I ever got to do on the office was when Michael's trying to convince everybody that they
don't need a new copier and all the chairs are good. And we had that gag, Jenna, where he comes
behind the desk and just tries to prove that your chair is not broken. And I had them rig up this thing,
because the whole joke is supposed to be he sits on your chair and it just sinks down below the desk.
他拍摄这一集最喜欢的记忆之一。这是他要说的。第五季有很多有趣的事情，但奇怪的是，我最喜欢的剧集之一是“盈余”。这是一集人们谈论不多的剧集。我只是觉得它里面有一些最有趣的东西。我想我在那期间笑得最厉害。我最喜欢的梗，我在《办公室》里做过的最喜欢的梗之一，就是迈克尔试图说服每个人他们不需要新复印机，所有的椅子都很好。我们有那个梗，珍娜，他来到桌子后面，只是试图证明你的椅子没坏。我让他们装了这个东西，因为整个笑话应该是他坐在你的椅子上，它就沉到了桌子下面。
And so worked really hard to have them rig this chair up that sunk so slowly that Steve just got in it
and is just talking like, see, there's nothing wrong of this. And it takes you a few seconds to realize
that he's just very slowly sinking down behind the desk. And then just Steve just destroyed me when,
And not only is he down low, but he won't admit it.
And then the way he has to stand up is like, hey, it takes such effort for him to get
out of the very low chair.
So that was a real favorite gag of mine.
Well, every time he would get out of the chair, he would make some other different grunting
所以我非常努力地让他们把这把椅子装好，让它沉得那么慢，史蒂夫只是坐进去，一边说话一边说，看，这没什么问题。你需要几秒钟才能意识到他只是非常缓慢地沉到了桌子后面。然后史蒂夫彻底征服了我，当，他不仅沉下去了，而且他不承认。然后他站起来的方式，嘿，他从那把很低的椅子里出来需要很大的努力。所以那是我真正喜欢的一个梗。嗯，每次他从椅子里出来，他都会发出一些不同的咕哝
noise, and it would do me in.
If you watch my face in the scene, I have this really, like, over-exaggerated, furrowed
brow. I was having to make a very strong acting choice because I couldn't do blank. I couldn't do it.
I had to do something with my face. Right. I had completely forgotten about this scene and when I
rewatched it, because it's been a long time since I've seen this episode. And when I rewatched it
this week, I was like watching it and I was like, wait, is this chair sinking? Oh my God,
it's chair sinking. And it was so funny. It was so funny and it's so subtle. It's such a small moment.
And in order to make it work, I could not be sitting on the chair at the beginning of the scene.
声音，这让我受不了。如果你看我在那个场景里的脸，我有这种非常夸张的、皱眉的表情。我不得不做出一个非常强烈的表演选择，因为我不能做空白。我做不到。我必须用我的脸做点什么。对。我完全忘记了这个场景，当我重看它时，因为我已经很久没看这一集了。当我这周重看它时，我在看，我在想，等等，这椅子在下沉吗？哦，天哪，椅子在下沉。太搞笑了，太搞笑了，而且太微妙了。这是一个很小的时刻。为了让它奏效，我不能在场景开始时坐在椅子上。
So it looks like I'm sitting and then he comes over and takes my seat.
I had to squat.
Thigh workout.
And hold my butt and hover.
And you can tell a little bit, because in order to do it, I kind of had to like, you know, really like spread my legs to get like a good solid squat on the chair, above the chair.
Yeah.
It's like going to the bathroom in a porta potty.
Yes.
所以看起来我在坐，然后他走过来占了我的座位。我不得不蹲着。大腿锻炼。抓住我的屁股悬空。你可以看出来一点，因为为了做到这一点，我不得不，你知道，真的像，张开双腿，在椅子上方做一个稳固的深蹲。是的。就像在移动厕所里上厕所一样。是的。
Halfway through your pee, like your legs start shaking.
You're like, oh, crap, I need to work out more.
This was a workout day for me.
Oh, my gosh.
That's how we pulled off that gag.
Also, in this moment, everyone starts to realize that Michael knows about the bonus.
Oscar calls him out.
He's like, I think you know.
尿到一半，你的腿开始发抖。你会想，哦，该死，我需要多锻炼。这是我的锻炼日。哦，天哪。这就是我们完成那个梗的方式。此外，在这一刻，每个人都开始意识到迈克尔知道奖金的事。奥斯卡叫住他。他说，我想你知道。
And he's like, what's 15% of 4,300?
That's the surplus.
And Michael immediately goes $645.
And he's like, why did you say dollars?
And he's like, that's just how my brain.
works.
Yeah.
And Kevin goes, he's a genius.
他说，4300的15%是多少？那是盈余。迈克尔立刻说645美元。他说，你为什么要说美元？他说，我的大脑就是这样工作的。是的。凯文说，他是天才。
Then Oscar says, okay, Michael, what's 15% of 200?
And then Michael doesn't know.
That little bit of Kevin thinking that Michael is a math genius in that moment,
Paul Feak said him and his wife, Lori, love that little bit and that they do that bit.
That like, if someone says something, they'll be like, he's a genius.
Oh, they do Kevin.
That's their little bit.
all of this leads to a very big smooch.
然后奥斯卡说，好吧，迈克尔，200的15%是多少？然后迈克尔不知道。凯文在那一刻认为迈克尔是数学天才的那一点，保罗·费格说他和他的妻子洛里喜欢那个小点，他们会演那个梗。就像，如果有人说了什么，他们会说，他是天才。哦，他们演凯文。那是他们的小梗。这一切都导致了一个非常大的吻。
Andy and Dwight and Angela have returned to the office.
Yeah.
And once you piss Angela off, she's going to dig in her heels.
And she's going to make a very public show to Dwight that she has chosen once again
Andy over him.
Yeah.
So Andy is eating a tuna sandwich that he's real proud of.
He wants Jim to know, tuna, I'm eating tuna.
安迪、德怀特和安吉拉回到了办公室。是的。一旦你惹恼了安吉拉，她就会坚持到底。她会向德怀特公开展示她再次选择了安迪而不是他。是的。所以安迪正在吃一个他很自豪的金枪鱼三明治。他想让吉姆知道，金枪鱼，我在吃金枪鱼。
And Angela marches across the book.
Bullpin and kisses him.
Mm-hmm.
He's leaning back in his chair.
She lays on his lap and grabs his face.
Do you know what the stage direction was for this kiss?
Read it.
Angela kisses Andy with a passion we haven't seen since Jim and Pam in Casino Night.
安吉拉穿过隔间，吻了他。嗯。他向后靠在椅子上。她躺在他的腿上，抓住他的脸。你知道这个吻的舞台指导是什么吗？读出来。安吉拉以一种我们自《赌场之夜》吉姆和帕姆以来从未见过的激情吻了安迪。
I know.
I read that.
We had a lot of questions about this scene, though, Angela.
Oh, well, I bet I have some stories for you.
Dory C and Amanda C both want to know.
Did Ed actually have tuna in his mouth when you kissed him?
Yes.
Oh!
我知道。我读过那个。不过安吉拉，我们对这一幕有很多疑问。哦，好吧，我敢说我有一些故事可以讲给你听。Dory C 和 Amanda C 都想知道。当你亲吻艾德时，他嘴里真的有金枪鱼吗？是的。哦！
That was part of the joke.
Lee and Gene, who wrote this episode, they thought it would be very funny if Andy was eating something gross when I had to go kiss him.
And that's why he has that line, look, tuna, tuna fish sandwich, just like you.
Because they really wanted to make sure the audience knew he was eating this smelly tuna fish sandwich.
And I was supposed to go over and we're supposed to have this huge kiss.
while he has tuna fish in his mouth.
And then you see me get up and I wipe my mouth.
Yeah.
那是笑话的一部分。写这一集的李和吉恩认为，如果我不得不去亲吻安迪时，他正在吃某种恶心的东西，那会非常有趣。这就是为什么他有那句台词：“看，金枪鱼，金枪鱼三明治，就像你一样。”因为他们真的想确保观众知道他正在吃这个臭烘烘的金枪鱼三明治。我本该走过去，我们本该有一个巨大的吻，而他嘴里却含着金枪鱼。然后你看到我站起来，擦了擦嘴。是的。
Ed was so sweet.
He said, Angela, I am going to hold my lips together.
I'm going to take a deep breath.
I'm going to take a bite of the tuna fish sandwich.
And then I am going to purse my lips together and not open them at all because I don't want you to get any of this tuna fish.
I was like, oh, Ed, that is so sweet.
And so we literally did, you know, what we call like grandparent kissing where you're just like,
he did not open his lips for a second. And they really wanted me to sort of have this long kiss, right?
艾德太贴心了。他说：“安吉拉，我会把嘴唇闭紧。我会深吸一口气。我会咬一口金枪鱼三明治。然后我会把嘴唇抿在一起，一点也不张开，因为我不想让你沾到任何金枪鱼。”我说：“哦，艾德，你太贴心了。”所以我们真的做了，你知道，我们称之为“祖父母式的亲吻”，就是你只是……他一秒钟都没有张开嘴。他们真的希望我能有那种长吻，对吧？
Yeah. And I was in control. I was the one that grabbed him and then I was the one that released him.
And I remember one time they were like, can you sell it a little bit more? Can you make it a little bit bigger of a moment?
And poor Ed, the minute we broke apart, he went, because he hadn't been breathing?
He was holding his breath with a big bite of tuna for sandwich in his mouth.
Here's my question. Couldn't Phil have made faky tuna fish? I don't know. Would that have been better?
I don't know. I mean, what could it have been? I don't know. You could have maybe, I mean, whatever it is, it's going to be mayo based. But it could have been chopped up chicken. I would have bought it. But it's not as stinky. It's true. But Ed was a true gentleman. He kept his mouth closed. I didn't get any tuna fish on my person. And you guys, when my character's
stands up and says, and now I have a legal issue to attend to, I actually had a big speech that got
deleted.
是的。而且我掌握着主动权。是我抓住了他，也是我放开了他。我记得有一次他们说：“你能再卖力一点吗？你能让这一刻更宏大一点吗？”可怜的艾德，我们一分开，他就喘着气，因为他一直没呼吸？他嘴里含着一大口金枪鱼三明治，屏住了呼吸。这是我的问题。菲尔难道不能做假的金枪鱼吗？我不知道。那样会更好吗？我不知道。我的意思是，它可能是什么？我不知道。你也许可以，我的意思是，无论它是什么，它都会是蛋黄酱基底的。但它可能是切碎的鸡肉。我会买账的。但它没那么臭。确实。但艾德是个真正的绅士。他一直闭着嘴。我身上一点金枪鱼都没沾到。还有，伙计们，当我的角色站起来说“现在我有一个法律问题要处理”时，我其实有一大段被删掉的演讲。
Really?
Yes.
And I was so nervous to do it because it was one of those moments where I had a speech in the
bullpen with everyone looking at me.
This is how the script described everyone reacting to the kiss and my speech after.
Okay.
Everyone watches with disgust.
Dwight's eyes go wide.
真的吗？是的。我当时很紧张，因为那是那种我在办公区里，每个人都看着我的时刻。剧本是这样描述大家对那个吻以及我之后演讲的反应的。好的。每个人都厌恶地看着。德怀特的眼睛瞪大了。
Angela pulls away.
Andy continues to chew and then swallows the bite.
Angela wipes her mouth and here's the speech.
I would marry you during an earthquake in the middle of a tornado.
I would marry you in the front row of an Elton John concert.
I don't care how terrible a place it is.
I just want to be with you.
Now, I have a legal matter to clear up.
安吉拉走开了。安迪继续咀嚼，然后咽下了那一口。安吉拉擦了擦嘴，演讲开始了：“即使在地震中，在龙卷风中心，我也会嫁给你。我会在埃尔顿·约翰演唱会的前排嫁给你。我不在乎那地方有多糟糕。我只想和你在一起。现在，我有一个法律问题要处理。”
Not an Elton John fan.
Clearly.
Clearly not.
But yeah, so I had that speech I had to do.
And they gave me a few alts, you know.
I was really nervous, but all that made it in was now I have a legal matter to clear up.
And I actually think that was a good edit because the kiss was enough.
Yeah.
显然不是埃尔顿·约翰的粉丝。显然不是。但是的，我必须做那段演讲。他们给了我几个备选方案，你知道的。我当时真的很紧张，但最终保留下来的只有“现在我有一个法律问题要处理”。我其实认为那是一个很好的剪辑，因为那个吻已经足够了。是的。
Right?
That was enough of like shoving it in Dwight's face.
I didn't need to make this speech.
But yes, no tuna.
Thank you, Ed.
Very different from a kiss with Rain who would.
Actually was eating tuna in real life.
Backstage for no reason at all.
对吧？这已经足够在德怀特面前炫耀了。我不需要做那段演讲。但是的，没有金枪鱼。谢谢你，艾德。这和雷恩的吻非常不同，他实际上在现实生活中真的在吃金枪鱼。在后台，毫无理由地。
Knowing he has.
Yes.
that are drinking coffee while eating like an everything bagel that had onions on it.
Yeah.
Different.
Very different.
Approaches.
This whole copier chair thing is going to wrap up.
知道他有。是的。一边喝咖啡一边吃那种有洋葱的“一切”百吉饼。是的。不同。非常不同的方法。这整个复印机和椅子的事情就要结束了。
The employees are going to confront Michael in his office.
And he basically tells them, you know what?
You decide.
You all have to agree or else I'm taking the bonus.
Because he kind of thinks like there's no way that's going to happen, right?
Of course.
he thinks there's no way. He thinks he got him. They very quickly decide to get the chairs.
He was like, son of a. He actually says mother. Yeah, he does. F. Was he putting sugar in his
员工们要去他的办公室找迈克尔对质。他基本上告诉他们：“你知道吗？你们决定吧。你们必须达成一致，否则我就拿走奖金。”因为他觉得这根本不可能发生，对吧？当然。他觉得这不可能。他以为他拿捏住他们了。他们很快就决定要椅子了。他说：“该死的。”他实际上说的是“妈的”。是的，他说了。F。他是在往他的……里加糖吗？
Diet Coke? He was. Yeah, he wanted to sweeten it. Oh, my Lord. The whole thing kind of ends with
Michael. He has a talking head. He wants you to know what he learned. What did he learn? He learned that
his team is faster at making a decision than he thought. He always, he always, he always, he always,
He also learned you should never buy a fur coat with a credit card until you actually have the money to pay for it.
Michael, why in the world are you buying a fur coat? You're never going to wear it.
It's ridiculous looking.
Yes. He's just like a kid that gets money and doesn't know what to do with it.
In his mind, that's, I don't know, fancy luxury or something.
健怡可乐？他是。是的，他想让它变甜。哦，天哪。整件事以迈克尔结束。他有一个采访镜头。他想让你知道他学到了什么。他学到了什么？他学到了他的团队做决定的速度比他想象的要快。他总是，他总是，他总是，他总是……他还学到，在你有钱支付之前，永远不要用信用卡买皮草大衣。迈克尔，你到底为什么要买皮草大衣？你永远不会穿它的。看起来太荒谬了。是的。他就像一个得到钱却不知道该怎么花的孩子。在他看来，那是，我不知道，时髦的奢侈品之类的东西。
Yeah, fancy people have those or something.
I guess so. The third thing he learned is that people think it's cool to throw fake blood on you as you leave Burlington Coat Factory.
So he has a ruined fur coat that he bought on credit.
That he can't afford.
Yeah.
That's how his day ended.
Jim and Pam's day is going to end with a truce.
是的，时髦的人有那些东西之类的。我想是吧。他学到的第三件事是，当你离开伯灵顿大衣工厂时，人们认为往你身上扔假血很酷。所以他有一件用信用卡买的、被毁了的皮草大衣。他买不起。是的。他的一天就是这样结束的。是的。吉姆和帕姆的一天将以休战结束。
But oh, can you make me three copies of this?
I'm just kidding.
I need four.
Is this Jim Sass?
Oh, that's some Jim Sass.
I have one final question for you.
Yes.
Would you be team copier or team chair?
但是，哦，你能帮我复印三份这个吗？开个玩笑。我需要四份。这是吉姆的讽刺吗？哦，那真是吉姆式的讽刺。我还有一个最后的问题要问你。是的。你会选复印机队还是椅子队？
Team chair.
What would you be?
Team chair. Yeah, team copier doesn't even make any sense to me, frankly. I mean, I would just suffer
through a crappy machine. How many times have you worked in an office where either the fax machine?
I know I'm a dinosaur or the copier didn't work great. But a chair, that's like your tailbone. That's
your spine. That's your butt. Is anyone team copier? Can we put a poll in Office Ladies Pod today?
Yes. I'm so curious. I'll put a poll and we'll see. We want to see. Well, you guys, that was
spend the surplus.
椅子队。你会选什么？椅子队。是的，坦率地说，复印机队对我来说根本说不通。我的意思是，我宁愿忍受一台烂机器。你曾在多少个办公室工作过，要么传真机——我知道我是个老古董——要么复印机不好用？但椅子，那是你的尾骨。那是你的脊椎。那是你的屁股。有人选复印机队吗？我们今天能在《办公室女士》播客里发起投票吗？好的。我太好奇了。我会发起投票，我们拭目以待。我们想看看。好吧，伙计们，那就是“花掉盈余”。
And also Angela's birthday.
Hey!
Whoop, whoo!
Yay!
Angela!
Next time I talk to you guys,
I'll be American surveyed, 50 to 75.
还有安吉拉的生日。嘿！呜呼！耶！安吉拉！耶！下次我和你们谈话时，我就要进行美国人口普查了，50到75岁。
That'll be me.
See you next week.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
那将是我。下周见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。本集最初是与 Earwolf 合作制作的。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。
Our second drinks episodes are produced
by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer
is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's
executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered
by Bill Schultz. Our theme song
is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
Hey y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey 的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertry》。嘿，大家好。我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表 Wayfair。
Ever order furniture online and wonder
what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
Visit wayfair.ca.
Wayfair, every style, every home.
有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想“万一呢”？比如，万一它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从 Wayfair 订购。有了 Wayfair，就没有“万一”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问 wayfair.ca。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。